Three,
two,
one that a gun.
That's a real gun.
Gentlemen.
We're live.
It'll be all right.
Yeah,
thanks.
[inaudible].
How are you fuckers doing great man.
It's great to be on the show again.
Great to have you guys here.
Um,
you know,
I was watching your instagram the other
day and I was looking at you with fake
hips doing crazy fucking heavy dead
lifts.
Man,
that's amazing.
I am starting to dead lift a little bit
more because I've been doing this
carnivore diet and I feel great and
there's no reason not to,
right?
So,
um,
I just figured if I can do it and it
doesn't hurt,
Diana,
why not?
So,
uh,
I was going up until about 400 pounds,
but I think I can still,
I think I can even get stronger now.
So what I am so happy about is this is
something squatting and deadlifting.
It's something that was part of my life
all growing up.
I was a power lifter all growing up and
he's the one who got me into this shit
and it,
it got taken away from me and I was
really sad and disappointed.
Became a drug addict and an alcoholic
because of it.
And now I can lift again.
So I feel good.
Is that unusual for someone who's got
artificial hips to be able to do
something like that?
Um,
do you know how many people don't know
that I have artificial hips?
Well,
I do know that Ed Cohen,
who is the greatest power lifter of all
time,
he has two fake hips now,
right?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think he's still squat 600 gs
at Eddie cone.
Check him out.
He's a beast.
Fake hips squatting 600 pounds.
It sees that.
It's like one of the most effective
replacement surgeries that they do is
replacing.
Yeah,
I think it's a great and a big deal.
I think it's a great surgery.
Before I got it done,
I mean I couldn't even get up out of a
chair.
I was,
I'd be stuck,
you know,
I stick places and um,
before I got it done I couldn't really
move at all.
And then after I got it done,
they had botched one side.
So one side went perfect.
The other side for two years was all
screwed up and the doctors didn't know
it.
What was screwed up about it?
Um,
the,
the cup,
there's a cup and then there's the ball
that goes into the cup.
The Cup came loose and it would,
it would shift around.
Now they think that the cup comes loose
because when you do both hips at the
same time,
they hammer one hip and the one side and
then you're completely like a dead body
almost and they flip you over and it's
really an island actually when they flip
you over,
they think that's when the hit might
that that socket may come out.
So they're starting to to question doing
them both on the same day.
Now,
yeah,
I've heard of people getting one done
and then a couple months later I would
recommend getting one done because then
when I got my other one,
when I got the one that was messed up
redone and I had one good leg and one,
you know,
one leg to recover on,
it was so much easier.
I didn't have to have the special toilet
and all the other students are going to
be on crutches instead of being in a
wheelchair.
Probably right.
If you only had one bathroom.
I actually wasn't even on crutches.
I came home from the hospital and that
day that I came home from the hospital I
was,
I was walking,
I even climbed a ladder and our mom
yelled at us and yelled at me because I
climbed the ladder and she's like,
what are you doing?
He just got a hip surgery and I'm like I
gotta change this light bulb.
I would think that one good benefit
about weightlifting with the increase in
bone density and that he would want that
if you have artificial hips especially
cause you got that bar that goes down
deep into the bone.
The hips got a Dexa scan done.
Weird shit going on.
We got really weird shit going on.
We had a Dexa scan done and Dr. Jacob
Wilson told us that our Boleyn,
was it bone mineral density density
density.
Yeah,
it was mine.
Mine was like off the charts,
but his was way off the charts.
And then we also got a biopsy done by a
Dr Andy Galpin and he's just like,
dude,
I love that guy.
He's like,
I don't the fuck's going on with your,
with my muscle and his muscle.
He's like,
but we need to talk about this morning.
So it's called steroids.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
So he said he wanted to interview me
more in and talk to me more about like
what I've taken over the years ago.
It was different than works.
It works fantastic when people,
I just think I heard you talking the
other day about throwing a roundhouse
kick and he said it's a second nature to
you.
And I think for us,
we've been lifting for so long,
a lot of this stuff,
even when I was a drug addict and
alcoholic the entire time,
I still trained every day.
I wasn't doing as good of a job,
but I still would make it to the gym
everyday.
It's ingrained in us.
It's something that we've been doing
forever.
So I think the body is just designed for
it.
It's essentially designed for,
not design,
but you've sort of designed it and I
think it's something that found us,
you know,
like,
like we did kind of stumble upon it but
I think it's something that found us and
it's uh,
you know,
I was strong right out of the gate.
He was strong right out of the gate.
I mean I remember,
uh,
my friend's benching in the garage and
they were benching the bar,
maybe a 10 on each side and I was,
you know,
doing a plate,
doing one 85,
12 years old,
you know,
he was an animal when he was younger.
It's just something there,
there some sort of strength.
My Mom,
our mom bench,
what she meant to be fine.
Yeah,
she'd been mom can bench one 35 like
right off,
you know,
like without ever lifting.
I want to say,
I think she benched one 85 she might've
in the same day cause she ideas would
say immigrant mentality because your
mother from,
where's she from?
She's a Polish right?
You Go,
I just got some of my heart thought.
I'm just,
I'm just white
mix getting 23 and me done.
I got one of those things done and I,
yeah,
I'm like Irish and I'm like only 4% of
the,
and I thought we were more,
but it makes kind of sense.
Our grandmother was directly from
Sicily,
so I don't,
I don't understand how that happened.
Yeah.
We don't know what's going on.
Well even if she's from Sicily,
who knows?
Like how,
what happened?
She was over there.
She came from,
yeah.
Yeah.
I know.
I need to get mine done.
I've been wanting to get it done for
awhile.
It's pretty cool.
Someone a lot to tell you like
allergies,
they get mad.
People get mad.
The people will not really native
American.
They get rid of,
they get mad.
I think it was spiritual.
People were like,
I could drink so much because I'm Irish.
And then they find out they're not.
Yeah,
you're just a drug like that.
And it happens all the time.
People get really upset because they're
not what they've been rooting for.
The alliance.
People take great pride in that for some
reasons that you were so dumb.
Yeah.
Where you're from.
Who Cares?
I'm American control over that.
Yeah.
I,
I wish I was something stupid,
but there is,
I mean it not like one.
Yeah,
Polish is a silly one,
but in my mind they're fucking hard
people.
I've known a lot of Polish people and
like dare fucking tough people.
Like you want to Nj check.
That's a perfect example.
Some of the fighters Polidori Geraldine
and Kovach.
Kovich that's that a beast.
Nope.
No,
that woman I should say.
Yeah,
those,
those ladies are fucking tough.
Like when I was a kid watching pro
wrestling,
Ivan put ski the whole fucking Jack.
He was,
now he works at a Strip club in Vegas.
Does he still alive Polish power?
Like to go to that Strip club to shake
that guy.
But I know that um,
a bunch of the wrestlers worked at
Cheetahs.
I know the Godfather,
the wrestler,
the Godfather,
he still manages Cheetahs I guess.
And I think some of these real quick and
real life,
he's a real pantsuit.
I was watching some clips from last
night from wrestlemania and Ronda Rousey
was with Kurt Angle and I was looking at
Kurt Angle's body.
I was like wow,
that guy's gone through some damage
damage.
Lots of neck surgeries.
Well you could see it in his arms.
The neck surgeries you see in guy's arms
cause their arms atrophy.
Right.
He's at your feet a lot.
Yeah cause it's fucking neck.
Looks like a goddamn treat.
Trump,
he's just got this neck that starts
above his ears.
His arms are not nearly as to say as it
used to be.
I think it's nerve damage.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
I had Pat Miletich in here a couple of
weeks ago,
you know former UFC champion pat and
he's got one arm that's smaller than the
other one boss route and to be here
tomorrow,
he's got the same issue.
Savage next neck issues for what you
know.
And I had a bulging disc in my neck and
I was getting weird,
a numbness in my hands and then nerve
pain in my elbow,
elbow,
the Ulnar nerve.
It goes on there and when you ignore
that shit and then keep training and
keep getting your fucking neck yanked
on,
then the disc starts to decay.
And then the pressing against the,
the the nerves and the,
um,
the,
the spinal column,
it gets worse and then it starts
atrophying and cutting off the,
the nerves to your arms and you get to
the point where you're,
you're shit just shrinks and it doesn't
come back.
A lot of that stuff happens in your
sleep to like,
something gets aggravated from training,
but you sleep.
Where'd you sleep with your neck?
All twisted.
You know,
that happened to Brian Shaw,
but Brian Shaws 415 pounds.
But he said he wished he had a good
story for why his arm was atrophying,
but it was a,
he lost his grip strength 100%.
He's the world's strongest,
strongest man.
Yeah.
14 lost his grip strength and it was
mainly all through sleep.
Got To sleep apnea,
study done,
and then he got a see CPAP,
the c to help actually cured everything.
He tried to do any and everything.
He was doing all kinds of different
things to get his hand strength back and
it turned out his mainly asleep.
He's too big to sleep on his side.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
So how's you have to sleep face forward?
I think he has to sleep on his back.
I should get one of them.
Massage tables,
just sleep at his whole,
it was facing the wall.
I want to do that.
You fall asleep on those things all the
time and that's the only way to keep
from snoring is the thing with me.
I have a fat tongue and if I lie down on
my back,
my tongue,
I have sleep apnea too,
but I wear a mouthpiece.
I
don't the of how some of these people
taping their mouth shit.
Yeah,
you could do that where a chin strap and
you can breathe through your nose.
It'll help.
Yeah.
Because if you breathe through your
mouth and your tongue falls back and it
came out of my mouth for improper,
you're not breathing properly would wake
up with headaches.
I would just wake up tired and with
headaches.
And then,
um,
I went to this guy,
doctor [inaudible],
he's in Encino and he has this
mouthpiece that is essentially,
it's a mouthpiece with like a tongue.
It presses down like a tongue depressor
presses down in your tongue and it keeps
your tongue from falling backward.
It was a fucking game changer for me.
Shit,
I tried to tap,
just changed.
Yeah.
I tried to see pat for one night.
I might get this fucking good robot
bullshit machine out of my face and mark
didn't like it.
He got scared and I,
yeah,
I'm claustrophobic.
So it scared the fuck out of me.
Really?
Yeah.
I hated that shit on my face and I tried
the [inaudible] the nose one.
I tried the mouth when I can do either
one of them mouthpiece
really,
really bad and um,
it's cleared up a lot by just losing
weight,
but I think and less fat.
That's a big thing.
Yeah,
that's a factor.
That's a factor for a lot of people.
The fat and their neck and everything.
Just sort of,
I mean I was again and got so big,
he can't actually fatter.
So I mean I,
I could see why that's a thing with
weightlifters.
You know,
interesting thing.
You get so big that you can't sleep.
You still some shit on your shirt.
You spilled some coffee there.
That's the worst.
Trying to wipe it up from getting a
stained.
So,
um,
tell me about this carnivore diet.
Cause I had Sean Baker in here and he
talked to me about it,
but he doesn't have any science,
you know,
there's no like he doesn't have any like
real tests or any longterm studies or
anything like that.
And you know,
I,
I'm a person who believes in balance and
I think that you need fido nutrients.
You need plant fiber.
I think there's a lot of healthy stuff
that you'd get from plants.
Um,
I'm a big believer in eating meat
though,
but all meet you guys doing all me.
Yeah,
I think there's modified it and think
there's some one at a time.
But yeah,
I think there's some,
I think there's some holes in every
diet.
I think when you go and you make the
decision to only eat meat,
then some rational thought should come
into your head.
Maybe when I switch all the way to just
meet all the time,
maybe there's a possibility I'm going to
eat too much meat.
And so maybe that would make sense to
bring in some fruit and bring in some
vegetables just so you're not eating too
much meat for the simple reason.
Vegetables have been shown and,
and there's,
you know,
you can get a study to show you
anything.
Uh,
but there's study a study that's been
done on 200,000 people that went on for
14 years and they studied,
uh,
vegetables.
They study every type of vegetable and
they found that they were more neutral
than they were harmful or good for you.
They found that fruit was a little bit
better for you.
And again,
you can have any studies say,
wait a minute,
what does this study?
It's called the pure study.
Wait a minute.
They said it's the vegetables or
neutral.
What does that mean?
They're neutral.
They're just really help you that much.
They weren't necessarily great and they
weren't necessarily bad.
I don't know what the Harrison to what
though.
I don't know what their standard was for
what they were looking for exactly.
But main thing they were looking
for was uh,
it being protective in terms of your
heart.
That was their main,
they're the main thing they were looking
at.
And so they found out that saturated fat
is protective of your heart.
They found out that cholesterol is
actually protective of your heart.
It found out that salt is pr now it's
all like,
you know,
without,
you can't take in tons and tons of salt
because then something's gonna kill you.
If you eat a pound of salt,
you're dead,
you know,
assaults,
one of those things.
It's really good for you.
It's an essential mineral to a certain
extent,
but have to take too much of it.
So I think any of these things can be
done too far.
I jumped on a carnivore diet just to
give it a shot and to see exactly what
it was about.
Because you talked to Sean,
Sean Baker.
Yeah,
he was.
He was on your podcast.
I got inspired to do it.
He was already doing it.
So I was like,
all right,
let me try it out.
I tried it out and got leaner.
It felt better and I was like,
this is pretty cool.
And why did you start it?
So I was doing a ketogenic diet for over
a year and lost a lot of weight on that
was doing great.
Feeling really good man.
You look very healthy.
I appreciate it.
I still have a long way to go.
In my opinion.
This is a work in progress,
but um,
the reason I did it was really simple.
It's a dietary intervention.
Um,
I went through sobriety as you know,
I was a drug addict and an alcoholic for
about six years and when I went through
sobriety,
that's a,
that's an intervention.
Like they,
there's something wrong,
there's a problem,
we need to fix it.
So my problem now was arthritis and I
needed something that was like an
intervention that would get me from,
you know,
uh,
being arthritic and in pain and not
being able to lift to being able to
lift.
And so there's some of this might be a
placebo effect of me going like,
well,
I'm on this diet and I feel great and
whatever.
And so I'm,
I'm now lifting more.
Um,
some of it may be a placebo effect and
that's okay with me if it is,
but I feel excellent on this diet and I
think the reason is,
is I'm getting a lot more protein in.
I wasn't getting enough protein on Kido
because I was listening to everybody
say,
well,
it will knock you out of ketosis if you
eat too much protein.
And that's what I constantly was being
told.
But I wasn't muscular.
I didn't have,
I wasn't being able to put on muscle.
Well,
you,
you were constantly testing your blood
levels.
Were you using a meter?
Yeah,
every day.
About three or four times.
Like I'm crazy with it because ptosis,
the things that would knock me out of
Ketosis,
we're just like mainly anything with
carbohydrates.
Um,
I wasn't really having too much of a
problem with protein because I wasn't
eating a lot of protein.
But,
um,
there was,
there were things that if I cheated on
my diet for example,
of course that would,
you know,
he usually kicked me out of ketosis.
But then I also got to a point where you
become so fat adapted that you become
what we like to call metabolically
flexible.
Metabolic flexibility just means you can
switch from being a fat burner.
You know,
I'm mostly a fat burner for the most
part because I'm eating high fat.
But then if I do eat something with
sugar in it,
it doesn't really affect me that much
because I,
because I'm used to it 90%.
Yeah.
Going with the fat so I can kind of move
back and forth between those two things.
But what I realized on the Diet when I
switched over to carnivore the whole
time,
I was thinking,
man,
if I could just have an apple,
I would feel like I would feel so much
better cause just eating the steak,
it's killing me and it's driving me
crazy.
It was a killing just mentally I wasn't
ready for it.
I wasn't tough enough to just say,
okay,
I'll just have steak on a plate.
Well you automatically use intermittent
fasting almost cause you're like,
you don't always have a hamburger in
your pocket or you don't always a run
through in and out Burger,
whoever it might be.
But yeah,
you end up utilizing some intermittent
fasting and you're like,
fuck man,
the only food I have to eat as a
hamburger or a steak
and it was hamburger or a steak.
And I'm like,
well how about an apple?
So I talked to our friend Stan efforting
who's a bodybuilder and he's huge.
He jacked and he's also a power lifter
and soup.
The one years old,
two and fucking Jack Soup.
But one of the smartest guys I know.
And he sent me that study that I sent to
you with the,
about the fruit,
and I don't know if you watched that or
not,
but basically they did a large scale
study with fruit and they found out that
uh,
the fruit actually would drive blood
glucose down instead of,
instead of bringing it up when taken
with protein,
like red meat.
And so I'm like looking at this going
like,
well,
if it's not going to drive my glucose
up,
I mean that'd be the one thing I'm
concerned with.
Why not have some fruit?
And so that I'm in talking with Stan
about it,
he was saying like,
I think fruit is totally fine and I
think you can have as much as you want.
And so I sort of switched over.
And it's crazy though because that's,
that's sugar.
I mean,
yeah.
Your body.
How did you,
how was your body
glucose level?
They've done studies where they've,
where they've studied fruit toast.
So like everybody thinks fruit toast is
really bad,
but they think that because of high
fructose corn syrup and fructose is
really bad when it's outside of fruit.
But for some reason,
um,
fruit,
fruit has these phytonutrients that has
fiber in it and those things sort of
like protecting you from what's going on
in the sugar.
They actually,
there's Fido nutrients in fruit,
like say an apple.
There's certain phytonutrients in there
that won't allow your small intestine
and like absorb the fat.
And so it actually helps you to digest
things like red meat that have high fat.
There's fruit that help you digest the
sugars in them and not,
it's not like it share it out.
I'm not a doctor,
I'm a filmmaker.
So I started,
you know,
basically,
um,
ask a lot of questions that were a lot
of people and start figuring things out
and then it's trial and error.
Um,
right now I'm in the trial trial and
error part and it seems like it's been
working pretty good.
So No.
Are you getting your blood work done?
Yes.
Um,
just got my blood work done,
um,
from last month and everything improved
from Quito to carnivore.
I didn't really have any cholesterol
issues.
Um,
I didn't have any,
Eh,
the,
uh,
what was,
what,
what am my issues that we've had our
bloodwork done probably four or five
times in the last year or so,
I would say.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
not all the numbers are,
are fucking great,
but for the most part it's been pretty
healthy.
The cholesterol has been good to
triglycerides have been good.
Um,
this doesn't show up in your blood?
Uh,
just,
it's not in the hot,
not in the high range of,
you know,
of what,
what it shows you on the uh,
on the sheet.
And then we also had other people for
what?
Uh,
oh,
in terms of like the triglycerides and
the cholesterol and stuff like that.
So you're talking about,
well,
like what you soon,
what's not good?
No,
I'm just saying
everything's,
everything's been pretty good.
Like this last time I did have my,
um,
uh,
I had one of my markers Kinda high,
both had high c reactive protein and we
don't,
we're not sure why.
So that's something that we have to like
looking at what is c reactive protein?
It's a marker for inflammation and my
react specifically of the heart.
Yeah,
not good.
And I see this,
mine was really high on Kido,
but then after I went Keto to
carnivores,
it came way,
way down.
So I don't,
I don't know where it is right now.
And I also had a really hot mine
registered really high at a nowhere.
It was totally fine with all the blood
work I've had done.
And the last one I had done,
it skyrocketed.
People were saying,
well,
maybe it's because you worked out
beforehand or what you consistent in
when you ate,
when you got your tests done,
where are you guys on a fast train
beforehand?
So I might've fucked it up.
Oh,
you fucked it up for sure.
Yeah,
I'm saying it yourself after we,
you train,
you train like a fuck the blood work.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's a snapshot in time and we hear that
a lot and I think that that's important
to realize and recognize that um,
it's just,
you know,
this one snapshot in time and we
constantly change all the time.
So particularly important with dietary
cholesterol,
with cholesterol in the blood,
the way it registers.
If you have a big fat filled meal and
then go and get a blood test versus you
fasting.
It's like how was your body absorbing?
This is what's really important.
How's your body absorbing these
essential new nutrients?
Not like what,
what happens right after you eat because
your body knows what to do with that
stuff.
My cholesterol was one 90,
which is good.
I mean they want it,
they want it to be under 200,
but I thought it was really interesting
was my hdl went way up from a 60 points
when I'm going from Quito to carnivore.
Well are you eating a lot of fatty cuts?
Like rib eyes,
mostly rabbis.
I like a lot of dietary fat.
I like a lot of like meat fat,
you know,
I think there's a certain point right
because um,
I,
I don't know.
Before when I was doing the ketogenic
diet,
the fat is kind of free flowing because
a,
you make your bulletproof coffees and
you just dump it back and everything
too.
Putting butter on everything.
But when you have doing it,
yeah.
When you have a stake,
what's really nice about having a stake
is your rate about 65 to 75% fat
already?
Like just grinding corn after the box.
Yeah.
You eating corn fed beef?
Is that what you're going to be?
I eat both.
Um,
I think that um,
the difference between the grass fed and
the,
and the grain fred,
there really isn't a substantial amount
of proof of how much better that is.
I do know that grass fed beef has five
times the amount of Omega three.
So
you always want to pick grass fed beef
when you can,
but a lot of people can't afford it.
And also,
uh,
the bet for me,
the best meat is at Costco.
That's the best tasting meat that you're
going to find.
I've been everywhere.
It's my,
why is costco better?
It just tastes the best around for the
best.
They have the best meat and it's called
fuck some like expensive butcher shop.
It's corn fans.
Cosco standing.
Costco is all organic now too.
You know,
that's a weird word though.
That word is so loosely defined.
Well we didn't spray it with a fucking
dad right before we give to,
all right.
There is a,
um,
what is exactly organic.
You have to pay to get organic status
too.
That's a weird thing.
You know you have to pay a lot of money.
Cause I remember talking to the
bulletproof and night,
the guy was telling me like,
you have to uh,
to Dave Asprey,
he's telling me you have to pay money to
get recognized as being organic.
So I have some sort of,
that guy says,
well,
the fat.
Sure.
I know what I'm saying.
You have to pay to get it to be a,
I wonder if that's true.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's true.
It is true.
It doesn't mean I'm sure it costs money
to get tested and to make sure that
you're certified.
Yeah.
Inside,
something like that.
You had to pay money for it.
I mean,
there,
there has to be some sort of regular,
I mean,
but when you're looking at the standards
like that,
what does that mean?
It means no antibiotics,
no added hormones,
right?
Is that what it means?
I believe so.
Yeah.
Marines,
no pesticides.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
excuse me for plants and vegetables or
fruits and plants.
Um,
w the one thing that concerns me a with
grass fed meat is that you're eating
what you do.
You definitely get a more expensive cut,
but you're eating an animal that is
eating what it's supposed to eat.
Yeah.
When you're eating,
like I've had weigel beef and colby
beef,
it's delicious.
It's awesome man.
That's thing's dead.
That's a dying animal.
That's like eating a giant fat guy about
to have a heart attack.
I mean all that marbling that's not
supposed to happen.
Like you shoot a bison like a free range
bison,
you get a dark Ruby Red Hong Kong meat.
I mean,
and that's all I have to say.
I completely agree with you.
Um,
but there,
there isn't science to really support
that eating a cow that was fed with soy
or corn is necessarily way worse.
And so,
um,
I might just be stupid for waiting for
that to come out.
It could be worse on a second.
You just said that there's way more
omega fatty acids and grass fed beef,
that's omega fatty acids are essential
for brain development,
muscle development.
There's,
so there's so many benefits to a sense,
those essential fatty acids and if those
are more present in grass fed meat,
when you just assume that grass fed meat
is more nutritious.
Yeah,
I would,
I would say that it has more,
it has moral,
meg has more Omega three,
it might be more nutritious than in that
that particular a way that I say like,
you know,
is the cost benefit.
The other day I went and bought,
um,
grass fed meat from wholefoods 33 99 a
pound
for a filet,
1999 a pound at Costco for a flay.
The Costco one is so much better.
The one from whole food was almost not
edible.
Like it did,
didn't,
it didn't taste good.
It's real tough.
Tough fillet a at whole foods.
I don't know why they'd have crappy meat
for some reason.
Grass fed stuff.
Sometimes a little text message.
You get a sponsorship for Costco right
before you go?
No,
no,
no nails for suspicion.
The ships.
But what I'm saying is that,
um,
I've,
I've gone to a lot of places is try to
find what me I thought tastes the best.
And um,
you know,
so for me,
sometimes I have to like,
you have to eat a lot of meat and if it
doesn't taste that good,
you're not going to get through it.
So I prefer to have meat that tastes
better.
I like 'em for grass fed me,
I like to use grass fed beef patties
cause they're a little fattier and they,
this tastes really,
those tastes fine to me.
Yeah.
But the grass fed steaks just,
they don't really taste as good.
So I just kind of switched back and
forth.
I think these are some of the smaller
issues.
These aren't the main things that we're
really trying to fight.
You know,
my brother and I,
we just,
uh,
took on to do another film and he,
you know,
he and I are doing this one together on
nutrition and we're just,
we're trying to find out some truths.
I mean we're trying to find out about
grass fed and organic and all of these
different things.
But mainly we're just trying to figure
out how the fuck do we help fight
obesity?
How do we help fight diabetes?
How do we help people gain control of
their diet?
And I think that's really truly we're
talking about is control and you look at
it something like a ketogenetic diet,
in my opinion,
it's one of the few diets that can
really help people with control of their
diet because it can help break up the
cravings.
And that's really ultimately I think
where our fight is against.
It's against cravings while these
convenient foods that tastes so fucking
good,
while the credit thing space all the
time,
fine carbohydrates and sugars a little,
those are giant.
And when,
excuse me,
when you hear about saturated fat being
dangerous,
it is dangerous if you take saturated
fat with high levels of carbohydrates
and high levels of refined sugars,
right?
Doctor Rhonda Patrick went over that in
depth and it's really fascinating the
reaction that your body has to the high
levels of carbohydrates in the high
levels of fat.
So your body is either fat burning or
carbohydrate burning.
So when you combine the two of them
together,
you have a nightmare disaster,
but it's not the saturated fat that's
the problem.
It's a saturated fat in conjunction with
the refined carbohydrates and sugars.
And one of the things that they're
finding too is one of the big arguments
that vegans in particular have used for
high carbohydrate diets in,
in,
in relation to obesity,
is look at Asian cultures and Asian
cultures.
You have low levels of obesity,
but high levels of high carbohydrates.
But you know what else?
You have high levels of diabetes.
You don't have to fat to be diabetic.
How many people in China?
400 million people with diabetes there
break a record.
Their level slightly lower than ours.
Um,
in terms of diabetes,
but level
is higher than,
it's pretty high,
right?
Yeah.
Japan's level of diabetes per capita is
higher than ours.
Their body crazy levels are probably
pretty high too.
No,
no.
Their body fat levels are lower than
ours.
We're gross.
Oh,
of course.
They're looking at you and I,
and not the three of us were not gross,
but Americans were fucking gross.
Yeah.
You know,
we fucking dog shit and we eat and look
and speaking of dogs,
so we feed our dogs only to like species
on the planet that get fat are human
beings and the things that we feed,
oh my friend's cat is a cat.
It could be a dog but it's our pets and
people get fat ice cream.
You know we grew up like that.
We grew up eating oreo cookies,
having you know,
a plethora of ice creams and different
things and the inner cabinets or the gym
and do you know,
full on squat workout,
you know,
work up to 500 pounds and go home and
eat like you know,
half a gallon ice cream.
Just cause we didn't know any better.
It's not even true.
It wasn't a full workout.
It was just a squat as heavy as we
could.
Then we went home and you know,
but there's some benefit for eating some
sugar post workout.
Right?
Yeah.
I know Jim still penny he believes in
that.
Like he's into like gummy bears and
shit.
Like that is a big shift though in
what's going on in nutrition and what
people think about that co that
postworkout carb window and all that
kind of thing.
I think a lot of people have been
shifting away from that kind of stuff.
A lot of people have been shifting away
from six meals a day.
A lot of them people been shifting away
from fasted cardio and a lot of these
dietary like sort of myths that we
thought that we needed to do.
We're looking into it and going like,
wait,
if you don't eat after you work out,
you don't lose muscle,
you don't do that.
You know,
these things don't happen.
So do you need to do that?
Like it could be beneficial or it could
not be,
but we're starting to realize that,
you know,
maybe some of these things that we were
doing aren't necessary.
I think there's science behind it too
because there's money to be made,
so I don't think it really matters
exactly when you take in your carbs.
I think if you were just to have carbs
throughout the day,
I think you would end up with a similar
pump and you'd end up with similar
recovery levels.
I know there's a lot of studies showing
that,
but there's probably not a study showing
a,
if you took in 300 grams of carbs just
normally versus dumping some more in
after workout.
Well you guys know Rob Wolf,
right?
Absolutely.
He's awesome.
He's great.
But one of the things that Rob Wolf has
done is pretty interesting as he and his
wife will eat the exact same thing and
then an hour later they tend to the
coast and they have very different
results.
And this is something that's really
important to emphasize.
Everybody's body is different.
And some people just like,
I have one daughter that can't,
she's lactose intolerant.
She,
she drinks milk,
she starts farting,
which is seven years old.
She thinks it's hilarious.
She thinks it's Hilarious,
but it does hurt her stomach a little
bit and you know,
but she'll have like a little ice cream
and it's just start farden and she does
it on q two.
She goes,
there's something really important to
tell you how she nails you.
She knows like she'd been hanging out
with you guys to hanging out with Quinn.
That's his jokes.
But my other daughter and my nine year
old,
a zero problem with,
so it's,
um,
it is,
it's just a physiological thing and it's
a weird roll.
The dice.
I mean,
human beings,
we've very an color.
We vary in height,
we very,
in everything we've,
we definitely
very in our dietary needs.
And that's what makes,
it's so crazy to try to give people a,
any sort of nutritional advice because,
you know,
you can't talk in generalizations.
He can't say this will work for
everybody.
I can't get on here and say an all meat
diet.
I think you can,
we'll work for everybody.
And in some way,
I think most people are eating too much
sugar.
People that are fat and a carb period.
Well,
that's,
that's what we're trying to define by
doing a documentary.
What are the couple things that we can
point to and say,
everybody needs to do this,
this and this.
And then these other things are like,
I just wonder if the average American
only 800 carbs every day,
if people wouldn't be fat,
you know,
it makes me scratch my hydrate
requirements for athletes though.
Oh,
like,
yeah,
like my friend Cam Haynes who runs like
when he's training for these ultra
marathons,
he runs a fucking marathon a day.
That guy needs more carbs than the
average guy who sits in front of his
desk in his,
on a can.
Here's where carbon,
I may be really more fat.
You know,
like they may be you only,
you can only store,
um,
2000 calories of carbohydrate in your
body at one time.
But the normal average person has about
40,000 calories of fat just hanging out
on their body and they don't even know
it,
right?
So we have a lot more energy available
to us as,
as fat.
If we learn how to utilize carbs are
also crucial from one workout to the
next.
So if you're anybody that ever does
multiple workouts in a day of any of
these MMA fighters,
crossfitters,
they're doing multiple,
they absolutely need carbs and it's a
good opportunity like forget the car
window necessarily.
It's just another opportunity to eat and
to get in some calories.
And so I think for them,
post workout shakes and those carb
shakes could be really beneficial.
It's a problem with athletes too because
they're always trying to find the
optimum performance and you're
experimenting and you're wondering how
much of your mind fucking yourself,
how much of it is just because you
worked out too hard?
Like where's your energy level at?
It's that you didn't sleep good.
Is that your diet?
Like what is it?
You know,
and they're always trying to figure it
out.
It's a big commitment and a big deal to
actually stop what you're doing and,
and to eat because it takes you like
2030 minutes to actually eat.
Might take a 10 20 minutes to cook the
meal and then you have 2030 minutes to
try to digest it.
And you're not sure if you're doing mma,
you have intense workouts or if you're
doing crossfit or some of these workouts
can be really intense.
You're not sure how that's going to sit.
So sometimes for me,
I'm just like,
fuck it,
I'm just going to use intermittent
fasting,
but I don't compete anymore.
So for me it doesn't matter as much.
Well,
intermittent fasting,
it's absolutely beneficial.
And I think one of the things that we've
talking about,
one of the benefits of the Keto Diet
that you also get from intermittent
fasting is when your body goes into fat
burning mode,
you're,
your hunger goes away.
It's the weirdest thing.
That's an important thing to kill.
I had a really poor relationship with
food before I even started the Ketogenic
Diet.
And by,
by doing women too,
let's not talk over each other.
I know it's hard and we're all doing it,
but let's try.
Gotcha.
And so,
but yeah,
not being hungry has allowed me to have
a little bit,
uh,
you know,
I feel free now.
I feel like I'm not,
you know,
attached food.
I don't need
food all the time.
I used to think about food all the time
because I was constantly,
you know,
eating things with sugar in it.
I used to go to the movies and cause I'm
a filmmaker,
I love to go to the movies and I used to
go all the time and I had this rule
where during the movie was my only time
I could cheat on my diet and I could eat
whatever I wanted and it turned into a
cluster fuck because I,
I'd have,
you know,
I'd have like the little pretzel bites
with the cheese that you'd did ben have
sour patch kids and twizzlers and I'd
buy three bags of candy and pretzels and
I'd eat the whole thing during the movie
because the movie's usually suck.
And I need something to do to keep my
mind off of the shitty movie.
So I would eat the whole time,
you know?
And obviously that didn't work,
you know,
and I was doing,
I was dieting besides that,
but you know,
it wasn't doing anything because I was
killing all the,
you know,
all the progress I was making.
But by doing this Keto genic diet and
not being hungry,
it's allowed me to just sit back and
look at food and go,
I want that.
And I want that because it's good for me
rather than say I need this now because
I'm hungry.
Do you still do cheat meals?
No.
Well,
once in awhile I shouldn't say no
because then somebody will catch me on
instagram with a piece of cake and be
like,
that guy's a liar.
But the thing is I don't,
I try not to,
but there's things that that are
cheating for the carnivore diet that
sometimes like come into my life.
Like somebody makes a new bar and they
give it to me and they're like,
oh,
here,
try this bar.
And I want to just try it to see if it's
good.
So yeah,
it's off my diet and I'll eat it.
But my cheats are much less damaging
than they used to be.
My cheats now are what some people call
health foods now.
When you say carnivores,
you t you saying that all of your meals
or just meat?
Yeah,
they're just,
yeah,
just meet just a steak usually or um,
grass fed beef salads,
no salads for the most part.
Uh,
every once in a while,
like if I'm at a restaurant or something
and a salad creeps in,
I'll have a couple bites of it.
But,
um,
I'm not a vegetable kind of guy.
I've never really liked them.
But I do love fruit.
I like the sweet stuff,
but I don't like the vegetables that
much.
So how much fruit to you to do now?
About two to three pieces of fruit a
day.
Um,
like an apple,
like maybe two apples a day,
probably something like that.
And then how many meals and maybe be
one.
And then about two meals a day.
Like two,
maybe like two stakes or you know,
maybe for Burger patties or something
like that.
So it's not a whole lot of food that I'm
talking about.
I can't eat like Dr. Sean Baker.
He's an animal.
Eats about four pounds of meat a day.
He's a big giant dude.
But yeah,
he's six,
five.
He's a foot taller than I am,
so that's pretty crazy right there.
So yeah,
there's not a whole lot of food.
I think a lot of people want to hear all
meet.
They're just thinking,
um,
downing these giant plates of food.
But I'm not that hungry.
So I try,
I do have to try to hit my protein goal
each day though,
which is about,
you know,
I need a certain amount of protein,
so I need like 168 grams of protein or
something like that.
I went off the rails the other night at
a Peter Luger's in Brooklyn.
I saw that and we were,
we were so excited.
Ooh.
So good.
But we were eating steak and then I was
stuffed from the
steak,
but French fries were there.
And it's a weird thing,
man.
When you eat steak and there's fries,
you could be stuffed from the steak,
but you fucking keep pounding those
fries.
Those salty fries are still God damn
good.
Palate fatigue is a big thing.
And that's what a professional eaters
do.
They go from like,
they'll be eating ice cream and I can't
eat anymore.
So they eat some French fries because
it's a different taste salt.
There's something about the side food
with salt.
You could just stuff more in there.
If you look at like Brian Shaw,
the world's strongest man that we were
talking about before,
he uses a dextrose.
He takes like puts it on rice,
which is just sugar and he puts it on
rice so that you can eat more rice.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Just so he'd get bigger so you can get
bigger.
Yeah.
So you can maintain it,
maintain his,
uh,
his felt 440 pound body.
That's fucking,
well,
that's a totally different thing.
One thing that we,
one thing that we've tried to do is
we've tried to not celebrate,
you know,
I think that can be an issue.
It's like you do want to celebrate here
and there.
You want to have some fun here and
there,
but have control over that celebration.
Like you're celebrating,
you know,
you're,
you're a buddy's birthday party that you
never even talked to and you're getting
drunk and eating fucking cheesecake and
stuff.
Celebrate when you really want to
celebrate,
when you really kind of quote unquote
need to,
uh,
maybe you celebrate after you lost 20
pounds.
But if you celebrate,
uh,
by cheating on your diet,
it's actually like more harmful to you
than it is a real celebration.
You're hurting yourself rather than
helping improve yourself.
Now we do need to be,
uh,
we do need times where we do have fun
and we kick back and have a couple of
drinks,
but drinking or overeating,
a lot of those things,
even when you're trying to stay on your
diet,
they will almost always lead to
cheating.
I noticed that when,
if I overeat,
that's,
uh,
when I get hit with a craving sometimes,
so somebody might think,
oh,
I'm just going to stuff myself with a
bunch of burgers.
I'm gonna stuff myself with a bunch of
meat.
Um,
it,
for me,
it hasn't worked that way.
It kind of makes those cravings creep
back in.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
but it's also psychologically it's fun.
Cheat.
Absolutely.
Give yourself a little bit of a break at
some linguine with clams.
I'd say even like on a,
on a,
on a carnivore diet,
there's some things that I eat.
I consider them like slight cheats,
like going to in and out burger,
you know,
getting like a flying Dutchman,
that is no flying Dutchman is uh,
uh,
patty and then two pieces of cheese and
on a patty that's cheating.
Well it's the cheese because of the
cheese.
Yeah.
And,
and it's,
it's not grass fed or anything like
that.
So you're like,
no.
So they have,
who knows?
Well what I'm eating,
but at least it sort of fits on my,
my plan.
But those are so good that every once in
a while,
you know,
he stopped it in and out and get a
couple,
I'd get it with the lettuce on.
Um,
they give you way too much lettuce.
I think that they can be like an entire
head of lettuce.
And I'm like,
how do I get through this?
You don't like let us,
no,
not really.
Not a big fan.
And neither one of us love salad.
I S I said on instagram the other day
that a salad is fake news and people got
really pissed.
But what I meant by that was just that
people are dumping tons of dressing on
it.
Oh yeah.
And they're not getting in and getting
what they think they're getting.
And especially like a lot of salads that
you get at like a restaurant or just a,
they're not even very green or anything
that just got full of very teachers.
A couple dressings like mark sisson
makes a dressing that's,
that's pretty good.
Made with avocado oil,
I think.
Things like that.
And He,
and he says,
I made this dressing because I wanted to
be able to dump as much as I want on the
here.
And the more I'd dump on the healthier
it gets.
And I liked that idea because I eat a
lot of wild game.
Wild game doesn't have much fat at all.
Like if I talked about that chipolte lay
mayonnaise and I started eating like
crazy after you said it,
I had a ton of it this morning with a
steak.
That's really good.
I'll slice of pizza,
steak,
Dunkin and put a fucking Glob of
mayonnaise on my plate.
I'll dunk the stake in the mail,
but it's a chipolte lay lime mayo and
it's made with avocado oil,
so you're getting all these healthy
fats.
It gives you some nice taste,
and again,
because I'm eating moose and elk and
deer,
it was a very,
very lean meats.
If I'm not eating like a cow,
if not even eating beef,
my meat is mostly really wouldn't be
able to do a carnivore diet on those
kinds of meats.
Right.
I mean it's too,
it's too lean,
right?
Yeah,
I would think so.
You'd have to add fat,
other rabbit starvation.
Yeah.
Rabbits are extremely lean and you can
eat only rabbit and literally starve to
death.
Wow.
Yeah.
People have experienced rabbit
starvation.
She sounds crazy.
It is crazy because it's so lean.
Google that Google rabbit starvation,
what that means,
because someone told me about that and I
literally never looked into it other
than what they said,
but it's so lean that yeah,
your body just doesn't get enough fat
to,
butchers typically add fat to a wild
game,
like when they chop it up and stuff.
Not Protein poisoning.
Protein poisoning.
Also reserve for it as a rabbit
starvation,
a rare form of acute malnutrition
thought to be caused by a complete
absence of fat,
the Diet.
Oh,
that's interesting.
They call it protein poisoning and
rolling.
Yeah,
so because if you just eat rabbits,
like if you just have like a fucking
room full rabbit,
rabbit,
rabbit me.
But most people would eat rabbits,
eat my rabbits with potatoes and you
look at that rabbit starvation man
cannot live by rabbits alone.
The meat is too lean.
Add fats in a few carbs or protein to
the lap end.
I guess that's what a rabbit is.
And you can easily survive rabbit meat.
Lapin is typically to lean.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Leaner than chicken,
I guess.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well those little fuckers are just
running all the time.
Wow.
Interesting.
How to,
on a ketogenic diet,
I was up around 200 grams of protein
when I first started it.
That was just dropping fat like crazy.
Just drop me.
That's not a ketogenic diet.
200 grams of protein fat.
Oh fat is 20 grams of fat and I was
dropping,
I said protein,
200 grams of fat and I was just dropping
fat.
Like you know,
like crazy.
Oh yeah.
But then,
then it came to a point where it
stopped.
I think that's what everybody needs to
know is a and I on any of these diets,
they eventually plateau or stop and then
you have to sort of
figure out how to get around that
roadblock and continue to like lose more
weight or do whatever you're trying to
do.
Well,
some people just too much protein knocks
you out of ketosis because your body
takes too much protein in reverts it to
glucose.
Right.
I think that's a lot.
I think it's overstated a lot though.
I mean,
I think like if you have a couple of
grams over,
you're not going to be in trouble.
But if you're getting 500 grams of
protein or something crazy or even like
300 grams of protein,
I,
you know,
after a while you're going to get to too
much and you're gonna have that problem.
But I feel like for most people,
that's not going to be the main issue.
You know?
For me it's inflammation.
Inflammation is,
the big difference is when I eat a lot
of carbs,
if I go off the rails and I'll cheat and
have pasta or bread or something like
that,
I experienced more inflammation.
It's appearance,
more soreness in my joints.
I've,
I'm,
you get more fatigued.
You get,
you know,
like tired,
you get that insulin crash,
you get all those big factors that I
don't,
I just don't get when I eat clean,
when I eat just meat and salad and
vegetables and high fat diet and low
carb,
my body is just way more efficient and
just,
it feels better.
And the big thing that I keep trying to
stress to people is you don't need a
nap.
That fucking afternoon nap,
which I just thought it's something you
need.
All that is is just your body recovering
from lunch.
FM carbs.
Yeah.
You're fucking carbs at lunch if you
don't have that,
the day is much more efficient.
I get more done,
I have more energy and I was like,
when people say how do you do like all
these podcasts,
two podcasts a day,
like no,
I eat good,
eat good.
And it's not hard.
It's not hard.
Your brain is functioning all day long,
but man,
if I stopped at noon and had a fucking
pizza and then try to do a podcast,
I'd be here like going,
oh,
is this done yet?
I need to sleep.
They just get tired.
Yeah,
you get exhausted.
We've been doing this diet since the mid
ninety's since like 1993 I think it was
around the time we kind of started.
We've been doing them on and off for a
long time and more recently I used it to
drop 70 pounds.
But I think one of the,
one of the things with Kido that I
noticed was it almost doesn't really
matter that,
I mean ketosis all the time.
I think the effort to be in Ketosis I
think is important,
uh,
by getting rid of a lot of the
carbohydrates that you have the effort
to kind of eat a little bit more fat.
But what I've noticed is I don't think I
need to really go out of my way to eat
tons and tons of fat.
I don't need to be dumping tons of MCT
oil and stuff.
I don't need to,
uh,
I,
there's enough fat usually in the stakes
that I'm eating.
A lot of times I get ribeye.
Um,
sometimes I eat bacon,
a eggs,
things like that.
I put up on my instagram the other day
about seven or eight foods that I
thought if you just stuck to these seven
or eight foods for a handful of days,
you would lose a lot of weight.
And the response was amazing.
People were writing back and you're
like,
Holy Shit,
man,
I had lost 10 pounds and well,
a lot of people do lose weight off
Quito.
There's no doubt about that.
But even mark Sisson,
who was one that got me into it,
mark goes on and off and he thinks that
there's some benefit to going on and
off.
Yeah.
I don't think he has to be in Ketosis.
Ketogenetic Diet.
Yeah.
But even when
you go off,
you're not switching your diet to
spaghetti.
You know,
you're not eating,
you know,
fucking wonder bread or shit like that.
That's love it.
If you switched up spaghetti,
right.
That's your thing.
Pasta.
Well,
I like it.
I like it when I cheat,
but I don't like the effect on my body
for sure.
I just liked the taste of it.
Like linguine with clams is one of my
favorite things to eat,
but the way I feel afterwards,
it's not my favorite bread and butter.
Why is that?
So?
Why is that so?
It's amazing.
So good.
Well,
you know,
people are out in county.
They don't even know.
We always talk about this.
Hard roles used to go.
Yeah,
like a buttered roll in the morning and
we grew up in New York,
buttered roll with butter.
It was the best thing ever.
And out here they don't have him.
Thank God.
I'm actually glad they don't have now
you know and I've had that I fucking
love sour dough bread with grass fed
butter and honey.
Oh my God,
they had sourdough salad is really good.
What honey?
On top of the butter.
Oh,
oh all this keto genic sounds amazing.
When all this stuff going on.
I had been wondering when somebody is
going to make some bread,
like figuring out a terrible though it's
not that bad.
No foods is good.
I like their bread.
I make egg sandwiches,
no fruits.
I haven't tried out w I haven't tried to
make a lot of good stuff.
I know they just came out the waffles
that good,
that donuts and stuff like that,
but I think a lot of those things for
me,
they have way too many carbohydrates for
me.
Way Too many.
But I think isn't there something about
the type of carbs they have fibers in
them?
Usually they don't raise your blood
level bludge something like that.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
I don't want to eat regular waffles on a
regular basis,
but if I'm going to cheat and I eat what
they have,
you know,
and they also have a very low sugar
syrup to it tastes very good with some
butter.
It's just,
it's the best option if you're going to
do something like that.
Exactly.
You should mostly eat real foods.
Like I feel better when I eat meat and
vegetables.
That's when I've,
when I'm,
you know,
I had Jordan Peterson on and he had some
pretty serious autoimmune disorders and
his body was really in trouble and his
daughter had similar problems and his
daughter went to essentially a diet of
just meat and Greens and now I think
she's not a carnivore diet and she's got
a instagram page to documenting it.
But he went to meet and Greens lost a
shit ton of weight.
Let was losing,
I think he said he's losing,
what did he say?
Like seven pounds a month for something
like something along those lines.
Lots of ton of weight and looks great.
He said he's thinner than he's been at
25 years.
It feels great.
All is autoimmune issues.
We're done.
I think a lot of what people are dealing
with is inflammation that's caused by
too much processed carbohydrates,
too much simple refined carbohydrates
and sugars and the inflammation leads to
disease.
So if you look at what they call the
five scourges of health,
they are a obesity,
cancer,
cognitive decline,
heart disease and diabetes.
Those are all metabolic.
Those are all things that we get through
food and over half the people that are
in the hospital today,
right now
in the United States are in there for
metabolic issues.
So that's crazy.
It's crazy.
Most of the,
so more than half of the people that are
in the hospital are there because of
what they ate.
It is crazy.
And then you see a direct correlation
between the amount of refined sugars and
carbohydrates.
Human beings have adjusted and started
eating to the rise in diabetes and heart
disease and all these other issues.
And you know the,
one of the things we were talking about
before the podcast is,
sorry,
I went running today.
If for some reason I can't stop
coughing,
people are dealing with a lot of various
health issues and they're always trying
to pin like one cause of these health
issues.
And one of the real problems is when
people develop these ideological
answers,
like veganism is one of them.
They do not want to thank that there's
anything healthy about meat and that
what they do is the only way,
and this is the way,
and like I'm watching this,
there's a thread right now going on on
twitter between some cockamamie Vegan
doctor.
He's full of Shit and all these people
that are s citing science and and he is
getting pissed off and he's showing his
degree and photos of his degree.
They're like,
look motherfucker,
this is real science to the fact that
dietary cholesterol is necessary.
It's the building blocks for cells.
I mean it literally is.
It's the,
the,
it's the reason why your body is
converting it to,
to all the sex hormones,
cholesterol,
saturated fat,
your body processes that it's healthy
for your brain.
It's healthy for your heart.
All these things are a fact.
He's not recognizing the fact that their
issue is not saturated fat.
It's saturated fat in conjunction with
all these other things.
And that's a problem with these studies.
Like one of the studies they did
recently where they showed that people
who ate meat more than five times a
week,
we're much more likely to have heart
disease.
But that's not a good study because they
didn't say,
what are they eating the meat with?
What are you eating?
Are you eating it with Brett?
Are you eating it in a,
in a,
in the same as a burger?
Are you drinking a soda with it?
Right?
Like this is not a good study.
A good study would be have someone you
know,
get a large group of people,
put them on a carnivore diet,
have a large group of people put 'em on
a Keto Diet,
have a large group of people,
put it on a standard American diet.
Let 'em eat burgers and fries and
chocolate shakes and sodas and let's,
let's,
let's find out what the fuck it is.
Put people on a Vegan Diet.
I have had tons of friends,
including Sam Harris who was on a Vegan
diet and his fucking blood sugar was off
the charts.
He had to try.
It was trying to figure out how to stay
healthy.
Like he tried,
he tried it for a long time,
but he felt like shit.
And then he went and switched to fish
and he felt like shit just doing that
too.
And then he went back to me.
Now he's helping to answer the answer
always seems to come back to being in
the middle somewhere,
right?
Like somewhere we veer off so far and
we're like,
oh man,
we got to retos and we got cookies and
we got all this stuff being thrown at us
every single day and it's convenient.
And then someone will say,
okay,
you don't know more carbs and you just
go the complete route
and you end up with something like a
carnivore diet.
But I think just if you're just sit
there and think about stuff logically,
it would make sense to me that you can
overdo it on me.
Like I think you can overdo it on just
about anything.
Yeah.
I,
that's why I lean towards balance and
that's why I like vegetables,
but I can't talk you guys into that.
Yeah,
I think your balance is probably a,
it's probably ideal,
but uh,
you know,
the balance of the average American's
not great because I think they think
they can just grab and reach for
anything.
That's their level of balance.
Well,
I think the average American is just
trying to feed themselves.
You know what,
I'm just trying to,
they're hungry and they're tired.
And look,
there's a great top,
uh,
Henry thoreau quote that most men live
lives of quiet desperation.
And I think that applies to so many
different things.
And one of them is work.
Most people are fucking working all day
and they're sad and they feel like shit.
And when you get out of there,
you're like,
fucking Wendy's drive through.
Come on baby.
Hit me up with one of them fucking
double cheeseburgers.
Chocolate shake,
please.
Woo.
They get a little reward and you know,
and then they feel even more shitty and
then they crash and they get up and they
do it all over again with a fucking egg
mcmuffin and a cup of coffee with three
scoops of sugar in it.
And this is the,
this is the rollercoaster that most
people are on.
And it all started with them going to
bed too late because they stayed around
and fuck around on their phone or watch
TV.
I went to bed too late.
They woke up later than they wanted.
They're tired because they didn't get to
sleep.
They were supposed to get drank the
coffee.
Right.
And it's just,
it's this one thing snowballing after
another.
Now what are you guys doing in this
documentary?
Like what are you trying to document?
We're basically just going around
interviewing people that are sort of in
the know,
you know,
that are writing these books like Mark
Sisson,
Robb Wolf,
those are some of the people that we
interviewed.
And just asking them,
you know,
basic questions about diet and nutrition
and sort of seeing what,
uh,
where they stand.
And then,
um,
we're,
we SORTA,
we shot about 15 interviews right now
and then it's my job to sort of figure
out like,
well how does this all correlate
together?
You know,
so we,
we don't really have,
I'd say it'd be disingenuous for me to
come on and say,
this is exactly what we're going to do
because I have no idea what it's going
to be.
And I think that's the beauty of it.
When we shot bigger,
stronger,
faster,
I had no clue how that was going to turn
out.
And I think a lot of documentary
filmmakers,
they'd go in with like,
here's the point I'm going to prove,
right,
let me find all the people and string
them along and then figuring out how
they fit into the puzzle.
And if they don't conveniently fit in on
my puzzle,
they're out.
And I just,
I don't know,
I,
I developed a different way of doing it.
I just like to try to get as much
information as I can and then think
about it a lot and then put it in a way
that makes sense to me.
So you're basically doing the opposite
of a lot of these propaganda films.
Like this is one of the problems that,
and a lot of people that have had heart
disease or all these various issues,
they paid attention to some of these
propaganda films.
So there's a couple of Vegan ones that
are out there right now.
What the health that's been widely
dismissed by scientists and the
integration experts.
And I would love to interview him or any
of the doctors
that are involved in that because you
know,
why not let them see it,
let them,
let them speak their mind and let's hear
what they have to say and then let's
talk about it.
You know?
And I think that's,
that's another interesting thing because
the other thing I also feel is like the
guy that made what?
The health,
I just feel like he has good intentions
also.
Yes.
Right.
I mean he's not trying to like kill
people,
kill people.
He's trying to help people just like,
I'm trying to help people.
So he's over here going like this guy is
trying to help people eat and meet.
He's crazy.
The problem is I'm not doing that to
him.
I think like there is a lot of benefits
to a Vegan Diet.
There are a lot of people that could
benefit from it.
Can everybody benefit from it?
I don't know.
There's a lot of things missing also.
So I,
I definitely questioned it,
but I don't shit all over it.
I don't think that's the way to help
people that way to help people as a sort
of bring them together and figure out
what
rare that people do it.
Right.
And I think if you do it right and you
have,
uh,
you know,
some sort of b12 12 supplements,
whether it is a,
you know,
from,
um,
like,
uh,
Greens,
like,
um,
what do they use a,
the,
what's that
algae,
Maria?
The algae stuff.
There's dominic d'agostino uses right
now.
There's a lot of that stuff that you
can,
you can get your b vitamins from and,
and if they're not opposed,
I mean the,
well,
some of the simplest organisms on the
planet are mollusks,
you know,
and I know that people think of them as
animal life,
but they're more primitive than plants.
I mean there's,
there's certain clams and Molec seen
things like they don't,
they don't feel fucking shit.
They're not suffering.
They literally don't have the capacity
for pain.
And they're one of the more primitive
life forms on earth.
I mean,
we deviated from them 600 million years
ago or something like that,
but they're barely an animal.
We can call them an animal.
There are some.
But see what we say is because they
move,
you know,
because the clam closes its mouth.
We've decided that that's a living
thing.
It's move to,
I mean,
do you have to plant that aids the rats?
Yeah.
That,
that thing's awesome.
Or Venus fly traps.
Yes.
And the thing is,
plants are far more complex and their
ability to communicate and their ability
to even express predation,
pain and protect themselves through
various chemical,
uh,
means to protect themselves from
predation.
They changed the way they taste to keep
from getting eaten.
And there's been studies also that you
just play the sound of a caterpillar
eating leaves next to plants.
They recognize that sound and they
changed their taste profile,
which is just fucked.
Great.
And those are,
those are chemicals like Lectins,
things like lectins and stuff that,
um,
it can be very damaging to people.
A lot of people don't know,
but if he,
you know,
cucumbers and tomatoes and stuff like
that,
you're getting a lot of these lectins
that a lot of people are,
they have adverse reactions to.
So a lot of people be eating,
you know,
a variety of vegetables in our diet and
not understand why they still don't feel
good.
Uh,
they need to look into that.
They might have a lectin issue,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's entirely possible.
So a lot of people,
let me start it.
This film,
you know,
we were going to call it the war on
carbs.
That's what were,
that's what we were talking
about.
And that's,
that's what we've been talking about for
quite a long time.
But as we started to go through the
movie,
we were like,
Oh,
I dunno,
war on carbs.
Like maybe that's going to isolate.
And that's gonna a pigeon holed a movie
into one style.
But as we started interviewing more and
more people,
we realized that the problem is carbs.
It's a problem,
a war on refined carbs and vegetables,
oils and sugars,
you know,
sugar,
which is a refined,
you say cars.
We're talking about pizza,
basically an ice cream and all the,
all the excess things that people are
using.
We're not really tough oils,
refined carbohydrates,
refined sugars,
and these are all product to the modern
world,
modern industrialized world.
And they call it production western.
They call the uh,
diseases,
western diseases because they didn't
used to have these diseases on that
level in other countries.
And then when we started exporting
molasses and we started exporting rice
and everything else,
we were exporting to these other
countries that didn't have it.
They all got sick,
they all started getting sick.
You know,
they all started,
their obesity rates went up,
their diabetes rates went up.
And that's,
that's just proof right there that if
you eat that stuff,
you know,
it will have those consequences.
Well,
one of the,
one of the great ways,
um,
I've seen someone talk about,
I forget who it was,
it was discussing this.
There were saying,
look at humans teeth.
People did not suffer from the type of
tooth decay they suffered from.
Now what does that from what's from
refined carbohydrates and sugar?
That's what it is.
And especially sugary drinks,
like people were constantly drinking
soda.
I mean,
you are just fucking torturing your
teeth.
You're just throwing acid on your teeth
all day.
I can't believe I used to eat all that
stuff.
When I look back,
know man,
I used to eat all that and look forward
to it too.
Right.
And I,
I guess I thought I felt okay,
but I really didn't.
You know,
I,
but I like thinking back on it,
I'm like,
I feel way better now.
But back then I thought I was okay.
I thought I was doing a good job.
You didn't know any better.
I mean,
even doing a low carb ketogenic diet,
I was still eating a ton of vegetable
oil,
you know,
and stuff like that.
And that's just,
it was
just like I,
okay.
Chicken wings,
they don't have carbs in them,
but they're deep fried.
Right.
It's terrible.
So reading that.
Yeah,
it's,
I mean,
just stuff like that.
I'd say you still have in your diet and
not know about.
I used to have,
um,
I was doing a low carb diet,
so I figured,
okay,
I'll make a big salad and I'll dump this
dressing all over it and addressing full
soybean oil,
stuff like that.
You know,
I'm thinking about it.
Yeah.
So when you set out to do this,
what was the motivation just because
you're on the health benefits that you
found from adjusting your own diet?
I think just,
yeah,
I mean I just like to help people,
you know,
I like to make films that can help
people find their way,
find what's good for them or what works
for them and um,
you know,
they can take it or leave it.
I think this falls in the category of
addiction too because the place that he
came from where he was addicted to drugs
and alcohol,
um,
and he was able to overcome a lot of
that.
I think the Ketogenic Diet,
I think without it,
I think it would have been a lot harder
now.
I mean,
I think,
yeah,
I think the ketogenic diet played into
it.
And I think the reason
why,
why did it,
I did a ketogenic diet in Rehab.
So when I got to Rehab,
I was like,
I'm not eating carbs.
Like that's it.
So why,
why did that help you?
Um,
it helps with your cognitive function.
It helps you to,
um,
it does,
it helps your brain,
you know,
helps your brain work better habits.
And so,
um,
when I,
when I went to Rehab,
you know,
it was about 245 pounds and I came out
at like two 15,
uh,
from doing a kito diet and I started
training again a little bit,
but I was still very sick and I was
very,
like,
I was,
I was messed up at that time.
Like I wasn't right mentally or
physically,
I was just broken,
you know,
and I was ready for a change.
And so,
um,
you know,
it was,
it was very humbling,
you know,
it's still is actually to even talk
about it.
So,
um,
getting knocked down a little bit helped
me.
Um,
it also helped me to start back over and
start back over with,
uh,
with a better head on my shoulders.
You know,
cause I used to think I knew everything
right.
And now I think I know nothing.
And I think that that's important
because I have this white belt mentality
now that I use on everything and
actually got that from talking to from
Fabrizio verdon cause like he was always
learning,
always thinking I'm always learning.
Right.
And so I asked him one time,
I was talking about Simon,
he said,
yeah,
I'm a white belt mentality towards
everything.
And I think I've heard you talk about
that as well.
And um,
I think that's important though because
we think we know everything.
We start preaching all this stuff and
then I turned around and go,
wow,
I really don't know what I'm talking
about.
A lot of times I really better think
about what I say more.
And even now I'm just a lot more careful
about making absolute statements.
I don't make any more absolute
statements or things like that because
you want to be sure that you're
conveying the right information to
people.
What were you saying before the podcast
started?
You were,
we're going to bring it up again about
veganism coming from a religion.
Yeah.
Veganism started,
um,
with the seventh adventist church I
believe.
So there was,
um,
uh,
you know,
a group of people that had a church and
the guy that led the church as part of
the church was like,
you know,
they were following the Jewish kosher
laws or whatever at first and it was
like no pigs or whatever else.
Shellfish,
I think.
Yeah,
no pigs or shellfish.
And then the guy just said and like it
just sort of took it to a next level and
said,
and like,
no,
no meat,
no animal products at all.
And so these people that were in this
church where like the first real group
of Vegans,
a church,
I've seventh adventist I think is what
it's called,
is where it came from.
Like 1863 is when that like movement,
I guess started it.
But like,
sure,
I'd started early.
I'm sure people were doing it earlier
than that obviously.
But I think that that's where the,
the roots came in.
And I just find that really interesting
because it does,
you know,
it does seem like a religion.
It seems like,
um,
today it seems like a lot of times you
get,
um,
I get called out a lot on,
on instagram and stuff like that from
people that are Vegan saying like,
I can't believe you'd do this and Bob
by,
but I would never go on their page and
say anything to them at all.
Well,
so proselytizing,
that's a big part of this whole
community is it's,
there's the moral high ground they stand
on it.
And then a lot of these people,
especially people with Vegan in their
name and their screen name,
they always go after people and they,
you know,
they try to shame people and what
they're doing is in,
uh,
in many ways is a very good thing.
They're not participating in factory
farming.
Right.
They're not participating in the Harz
that we see in these fucking peta videos
where you see cows and pigs and chickens
are just being tortured.
All that fuck,
that is disgusting and that should be
eliminated and shouldn't be a part of
modern culture.
But in terms of like the humane raising
and killing of animals,
look,
they're not going to live forever and I
don't care what you say.
I'm not into animal suffering.
I don't think they should suffer,
but if you try to say the people are not
herbivores or that people are herbivores
rather,
and then we're not omnivores,
you're crazy.
It's just not true.
It's not fact,
and they show picture.
These are not the teeth of a carnivore.
These are the two that were,
we're not carnivores stupid.
We're omnivores.
A chimpanzee.
Yeah,
we,
we look real similar and our teeth to
fucking chimps.
Chimps are omnivores and the human diet
is a very complex thing.
When you attach that human diet to
ideology,
then it gets really screwy because
you're not dealing,
you're not dealing with people that are
being honest about dietary,
like what is really important and as far
as dietary requirements,
how your body functions,
what the studies show,
if you look at it objectively,
the objective,
the first thing anybody should say first
thing across the board,
Garrett,
all the fucking sugar.
That's number one.
Get rid of all the refined
carbohydrates.
Eat more vegetables.
I think you guys don't eat more
vegetables.
Eat healthy fats.
Get some formal omega fatty acids.
Recognize that the omega fatty fatty
acids that you get from flax seed oil or
not as bioavailable is fact from studies
not as bioavailable.
Is it mega fatty acids you get from fish
and meat,
they're just not the meat.
The protein.
Well,
Broccoli has 15 groups.
It's not as bioavailable.
You fucks and you know it's not.
It's just not.
So you can get bioavailable protein from
plants.
You get it from hemp,
you get it from [inaudible],
you get it from peas.
Pea protein is very good,
but it's not as good as the,
the protein that you get from meat.
It's just not,
can it sustain you?
Yes it can.
Can you be a healthy person and live a
fucking balanced life on a completely
vegetarian diet?
100% but I would always recommend eat
free range eggs.
You're not hurting a chicken.
Nothing gets hurt.
It is free food.
We have,
I have chickens.
They roam around,
they eat vegetables,
nobody eats them.
The chickens live a fucking healthy
life.
They lay eggs,
we eat the eggs,
the eggs are healthy as fuck ethos.
Find a place that has free range.
Chickens eat the eggs.
It's,
I mean it's not Vegan,
but it is vegetarian.
If you want to get rid of dairy and you
don't want,
I get it man.
I've seen gary dairy farms.
It's fucked up.
You see what they're doing at cows and
they,
you know what the way they treat them
and the way they're raised them and just
the whole idea behind it.
Like making them lactate.
The only time,
but cows.
Lactate is when they have a baby,
right?
So they keep them in this state and it's
just,
it's unnatural.
And that is a reality of dairy
production.
And if you don't want to be a part of
that,
that's a hundred percent noble.
But we have to be honest about nutrition
requirements,
not about the ideology of veganism.
And this is the problem with these
people.
And so many of them,
especially the ones with Vegan attached
to their identity,
because they use the name like v I'm,
I'm Vegan warrior,
this is Vegan prints and the Vegan
defender,
they're fucking morons who joined a
gang.
And what they do is they start eating
plants,
they start talking shit,
and they go looking to just go after
anybody who's not on the same page as
them.
And the real problem is people that
watch a movie,
like what the health or something,
and then think,
well that this is,
oh my God,
I'm killing myself by not being a Vegan.
Nope,
you need to google what the health
debunked and find out the actual science
because what they're talking about is
bullshit.
They're not being honest.
What they've done is make a Vegan
proselytizing movie.
They're trying to get people to join in
because that's what they do and a lot of
these people,
but they give up a lot of these people
to get to a point where their health
can't take it anymore and you fucking
give up.
Chris Kresser is a perfect example.
I don't know,
have you interviewed him for a film?
Not yet,
but we will.
He's fucking brilliant.
And he was a macro,
but he was a macrobiotic Vegan.
I mean this guy was all off the charts
with veganism and eventually realize his
body was falling apart and gave up on
it.
There's some people that owned that
restaurant in California and Hollywood.
What is it called?
The something cafe.
Gratitude.
Thank you,
Kathy.
Gratitude.
Yeah.
These people were,
I mean,
they're fucking health was falling
apart,
so they decided to raise their own
cattle and ether on meat and vegans
found out they got death threats and
people were fucking going after them.
Yes,
ma'am.
It was a terrifying thing for these
people.
They're all our folks and they,
they,
they have their own farm and they were
raising their own farm animals and they
decided to start eating them.
And when they made these posts about
starting these people went after them.
Man.
You know,
it's not,
this is not kindness.
And you know,
this is not someone who's compassionate.
He's a fucking cunt,
better in a gang and that they're in the
plant gang.
You know,
and if you talk,
and I'm sure you've seen it by doing
this carnivore diet thing,
if you do anything that's outside of
that,
they go after you.
Yeah.
Start jumping down throat just so
everybody knows you.
You keep mentioning,
ah,
you're not going to talk.
I sit in a like in vegetables or
whatever.
Uh,
I,
I do eat vegetables.
I casually,
if you have to find the way,
Mike Kenogenic diet before I went on the
carnivore diet was mainly a vegetarian
diet.
Like mostly vegetables.
I would eat a lot of vegetables,
big salads and all this stuff.
And I throw a little bit of meat in
because I was very concerned about
eating too much protein.
So I'd only eat 80 to 100 grams of
protein a day.
Now I eat double that.
And so that's sort of what the switch
was and it's just an intervention for
now.
Um,
I feel it.
I feel that,
I used to think that the best healthiest
diet for a human being would be a Vegan
diet with like three or four ounces of
meat thrown in it at every meal.
You know,
just to have the animal fat and animal
protein.
I like that would be really smart.
Now I'm starting to think the opposite.
I think front loading your body with the
nutrients that it needs because our
body's always in search for nutrients.
That's why we're hungry.
We're always searching for the nutrients
that we need,
the vitamins and minerals that we need
and all the macro nutrients we need.
If we front load at first and give us a,
you know,
a chunk,
a nice steak,
you're body's not hungry afterwards.
And I think that's what's happened to
me,
where now I'm sort of giving my body
what it needs and it never,
it's never asking for what it doesn't
need.
I saw a comment the other day and one of
those animal videos when those horrible
factory farming videos said,
because of this video,
I'm 60% vegan now with my diet.
What exactly,
what the fuck does that mean?
But that's the type of morons we're
dealing with here.
People that are not looking at
themselves or anything,
honestly,
they,
they're,
they're trying to stand on the moral
high ground and they've,
if they know the meat,
they can't.
So they say,
well baby,
I'm almost all Vegan.
Well,
okay,
well those poor little fucking cows in
murder.
The 40% almost everybody who eats a
balanced diet,
60% vegan.
That's riddick.
Exactly.
I mean that's,
it's a ridiculous thing to say,
but this is the problem is people,
they're not just eating things,
they're posturing like outs there.
They're publicly posturing on their
position on,
on morals and ethics.
You know,
you see it all the time.
Yeah.
We see it in every aspect of fitness.
We see it.
Oh yeah.
You see in all areas.
But I think there's also a difference
between,
um,
you know,
survival and there's a difference
between performance.
And I think,
you know,
we're asking our bodies,
all three of us at the table,
we're asking our bodies to do some
demanding thing.
So I think in that case like maybe we do
need a little bit more meat,
especially if meat is going to be kind
of our main driver of our calories.
And it kind of makes sense that we would
need a little bit more of that than
maybe your average person.
So what you said about the three ounces
of meat,
every couple meals probably makes sense
and probably be great for survival.
The other thing that's really
interesting though is that even for
those of us had been trying to seek the
truth and for those of us have been
trying to eat good and trying to train
and it's not like you're like,
oh,
there's Joe Rogan hundred 50 years old.
Look at that fucking guy.
Yeah.
You know,
we still don't really,
uh,
you know,
you're not insuring anything,
right.
But,
uh,
you're trying to just live the life that
you want to live the best way possible
that you can live at.
Yeah.
If I lived to be 150 those last couple
of years are going to suck effect.
I last couple.
Well,
I'm mean,
I'm not convinced that people won't in
our lifetime.
I mean with,
with science and fucking stem cells,
they said right now,
if you're born today,
you have a chance of living to be one oh
four is like that
one oh four,
I'm going to live to be one of four
bitch hit by a car.
Yeah.
Asteroids.
The thing is,
you and I and a lot of their people
listening,
we started 30,
40 years in.
You know what I mean?
We started too late.
I don't know when you started eating
better,
but I know that it wasn't your whole
life.
No,
no,
it wasn't my whole life.
Um,
I was certainly no high refined
carbohydrate up until 10
years ago.
Yeah.
I mean I've really got into,
I mean,
I've always been supplementing with
vitamins and I've been getting my blood
work done for a couple of decades now,
but the real shift was switching to
Quito.
Genic do you know where the shift came
from?
Me?
And you're probably not going to believe
this.
The shift came from me after going to a
show where I first met you,
very time we first met.
I don't even know if you remember it.
Uh,
it was outside the Ice House in
Pasadena.
And I came up to you and talk to you
with Brian Callen and you were talking
about diet and you were saying,
man,
I can't believe that people eat all this
shit.
And like,
you know,
you say every town I go to,
I like,
the first thing I do is look for the
whole foods and I find the whole foods
and I go get my food.
And I'm thinking like,
man,
I travel all the time.
If Joe Rogan can do this,
like,
why am I not doing it?
You know,
why am I being so lazy with my Diet?
I'm so fat,
like what's going on?
And I that day actually really made me
think about a lot and I,
I saw you as an inspiration after that
day.
I started really digging into it a lot
more so.
Well,
I spend a lot of time in hotel.
So what I would do is I would show up at
a place on Thursday and I'd be there til
Sunday,
you know,
especially when I was doing comedy clubs
on the road.
So I go to whole foods.
I'd stock up on Kombucha,
I would get a,
a bunch of healthy snacks,
a bunch of raw almonds and things along
those lines.
So that way I had something in my hotel
room all the time.
So if I'm writing or you know,
getting done working out or something
like that,
I'm not eating candy bars.
I'm done rating the hotel minibar and
eat bullshit.
That makes all the difference in the
world doc.
And that's how I travel now too.
I just have everything ready to go.
Yeah.
Get a breath.
Bring yourself a big case of bottled
water,
you know,
make,
make sure you got stuff in your room
that can sustain you.
And if it carnivores,
does it bring some,
uh,
sardines in a can?
Yes,
I do a lot of that.
I bring sardines.
I bring a oysters,
I bring oysters with me.
You're not going to believe this.
My first sardine I've ever eaten was
like two days ago.
Actually.
I just so,
because you guys talk about it so much
d'agostino we went and visited Dom
D'agostino and interviewed him.
He just kept talking about these
sardines,
so I'm like,
finally I got to try it.
They taste just like tuna fish.
The great southern.
Great.
I can't believe you'd never had
sardines.
Awesome.
They're great.
It sounds gross.
It they sound gross,
but I had him like about two weeks ago
as well,
maybe maybe a month or two.
Wild.
The Wild Planet.
Wild Planet.
Olive oil.
Yeah.
They also have macro and a bunch of
other different things that I was used
to.
The ones that my grandfather get,
we like peel the can down and then it
was like these little little fish in
there.
Those I love those look too gross to me,
so that's what I remember seeing as
Sardi man,
they're good.
I like sardines are very healthy for you
as long as,
well,
one thing though,
I do have to say I was eating a can or
two a day and then I found arsenic in my
blood.
That's right.
I heard that.
Yeah.
And then the doctor's like,
just lay off that,
let's do another test in a month.
And then it was gone.
And so it's just the,
there's a lot of heavy metals in the
water and they're,
they're low on the,
uh,
in the,
in the ocean floor.
I mean,
they're down there with all that shit.
Yeah.
Speaking of fish and stuff like that,
I do,
it's important for people
to get some Omega threes and if they are
going to try a carnivore diet and a way
to do that as either eat the grass fed
beef or to add in some a salmon.
So I add in salmon twice a week,
usually just pokey or something like
that.
Just eat it,
eat it by itself.
Oils.
Uh,
what about just getting some fish oil
and,
and taking that in.
Ah,
so I like,
I like whole foods and I like things in
the whole food environment.
And the more I do research on things and
look into it,
the more I realize like the whole foods
are really where it's at.
So I don't know.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm sure there's a lot of studies on it
and things like that,
but I just feel like,
um,
the way that the way that they make fish
oil and the way that it sits around
forever and stuff like that,
I don't know.
So I don't use it,
you know.
Um,
one of the things I do use because I
can't,
I can't stand eating it.
Second,
stand to eat the fish.
I like the fish.
I like the salmon.
Um,
I do not like liver,
but beef liver is the highest and
nutrients you want to talk about a
superfood is like these true superfood.
Yeah.
Way More than keen water.
And there's so many nutrients in beef
liver,
but I don't like it.
So I take beef liver tablets or capsules
or whatever.
Oh,
I love liver and those tastes,
yeah.
I don't know that I don't like it.
I don't know how to cook it,
so I've never actually made it.
Yeah.
All you do is take a dusting of like
ketogenetic flower,
like almond flour or something like
that.
Put It on there and fried in butter.
Just fry it,
slice that baby up.
Then fry with onions.
You like onions,
you're going to see a youtube video
then.
Huh Dude,
I got some elk liver.
If you want to try that,
that'll,
that'll fuck off.
You think beef liver strong.
He'd take out elk lever.
You're like,
Yo,
whoa.
You can deadlift liverwurst and I
thought it was pretty good.
Well,
yeah,
that's a different thing kyle.
It was pretty good too though.
Your Buddy Kyle Kingsbury,
he recommended the liverwurst and I was,
yeah,
then I didn't want to do it.
And um,
it's good.
It's just like mixed in with other stuff
or something really good.
I don't know what's in livermore,
so that's a good question.
It's liver and kidneys and hearts and
let's find out.
Well,
all those things are great.
Organ meat is the best meat for you.
And liver in particular.
That's why wolves,
when the Alpha is established in the
pack,
the Alpha will always eat the wolf or
eat the liver first.
I can one,
there was a,
there was this crazy,
uh,
thing that this guy was doing where he
was living with wolves and a,
he had established himself as the Alpha
in the pack.
And one of the ways he would do that,
they would have a kill and he would
plant a liver inside the kill and then
he would eat the liver and grout,
all the other worlds.
We would let him go because he's got the
liver because once the,
but then he had to leave in order to
help someone else.
This guy had a farm that was being
attacked by wolves and so he set up some
speakers and had some other wolves howl
and essentially try to convince these
wolves that were killing these guys.
Uh,
animals that a new pack had been in
town.
And with these big speakers,
these other wolves were like,
Holy Shit,
there's a lot of fucking wolves here.
Let's get outta here.
And he is literally worth,
but he was gone for a while,
I think for a couple months and when he
came back,
the other walls were like,
fuck you motherfucker.
Where
the Alpha now and he almost got killed
by these walls.
It's terrifying to watch him whimpering
in front of these walls while these
wolves are like inches away from him
with their teeth,
like big fucking wolves.
Matt,
why is the idea that while he was doing
studies on walls and they were all
contained in this large fenced in area,
which is also highly criticized because
there's some videos on,
on uh,
youtube that you could see of these
wolves attacking this one Beta wolf.
And one of the reasons why that
behavior,
so essentially it is the fact that they
are contained in a very small area.
I mean it's big in that it's a few
acres,
but it's small in terms of law,
what a wolf's natural roaming would be.
They do say that animals tend to go for
the liver,
like they know about it so long.
If you look at salmon,
there's a,
there'd be a bunch of salmon in a river
and like there'd be a big chunk taken
out of them,
but the rest of the body would be there.
And the reason it was a bear would
basically rip out its liver.
And that's what,
uh,
that's what it was after.
That's when the sector and full surplus
or Sam and everyone go get four or five
livers,
you know,
because it wanted to eat that.
So it's like looking at the salmon,
almost like an egg and that's the egg
yolk,
you know,
that's,
that's an important part.
Yeah.
Most animals,
like most predatory animals,
they go for the guts first.
It's really weird.
And back in the day,
I think when they used to kill things,
they would say that even human beings
where you all the organs first.
Oh yeah.
I mean Origami Kidney Pie and she didn't
like them.
I mean there was,
but they didn't know they were doing it
for nutrition.
They just didn't want to waste anything.
No,
I think the party,
I think you're right is great too.
I've got some elkhart and then probably
went with what tasted better.
Right?
Like you know,
eventually,
you know,
if the heart tasted great,
yeah,
let's,
the heart doesn't,
it doesn't taste the best.
The best is like backstrap and which is
the loins are the tenderloins,
you know,
which is the inside.
That stuff is the most tender.
And a lot of people feel like it's the
best.
Some people like in a cow,
they like in New York's trip it's like a
more,
uh,
it's got a more richer taste.
But most people don't find the liver to
taste the best,
but it's just cause it's a strong
flavor.
I don't know.
I've always liked it.
I've always liked liver beef,
liver desiccated beef.
Liver capsules actually tastes like a
fart.
I mean when you,
when you burp.
Ah,
no.
Just when,
when when you take them,
you can drink as much water as you want.
You're always going to get that little
like,
oh well he's like,
he's like a fart.
Wow.
You know,
it's like when you eat the meat,
it doesn't taste like that.
We eat the meat of the liver.
It doesn't,
it doesn't taste that.
I don't think you guys should be high
end farts.
Now,
Chris Kresser is a big proponent of
Oregon.
Me and he said when he had a bunch of
autoimmune issues as well,
and he said that auto,
that eating liver and heart and kidneys
and stuff like that,
all that stuff really helped him
tremendously.
I wish I like liverwurst more.
It's not that I don't like it that much.
Force yourself to eat it,
man,
and force yourself to eat cow's liver
when you don't really have problems.
You're getting calves liver most of the
time,
which is kind of fucked up.
You're,
even though you're right,
if you do for chuffed to edit,
your ended up actually liking and I was
like,
Huh.
You know sometimes you can eat it in a
place that cooks it.
If you go to a
really good restaurant that serves liver
and onions,
a good restaurant that serves it,
it's delicious.
It's just you've got to find someone who
knows how to prepare it properly.
Yeah.
You teach your kids eat healthy or is it
just kind of like they just watch a
night kind of like off of everything.
It's really unusual.
They've been eating from the time they
were really little.
I started hunting in 2012 so for the
last six years they've been eating wild
game.
So from the time they were little,
like my seven year old,
she doesn't know anything different.
She's eaten beef for sure.
She eats hot dogs and normal stuff that
kids eat,
but she's been eating elk and bear and
deer and you know,
Moose her whole life.
She's the wild Turkey.
She's eaten like basically all the
different things that people hunt for.
She's eaten since she was a little kid.
You guys talk about nutrition at all?
Yes.
Well the other thing that my kids eat
that's really spectacular to watch as
they love Kimchi,
especially my youngest,
she loves probiotics,
which is crazy.
Yeah.
We give them probiotics in supplements.
We give them probiotics and in terms of
yogurt and acidophilus and,
and these little uh,
Bio k formulas that are pretty rich and
they taste pretty good too.
There's some sugar in there,
unfortunately,
but,
but getting your kids into really
healthy probiotic foods,
it's interesting.
What's interesting is how quickly they
snap back from colds,
how,
how resistant they are to them and how
quickly they snap back for them because
they have this healthy biome,
this healthy immune system.
Kimchi is one of my,
I had some Kimchi today.
I eat it almost every day.
I get this a,
there's a company called mother-in-laws
Kimchi.
It's my favorite and I'll buy like five
jars at a time and I go through those
fuckers in like two weeks.
You don't see it by itself.
I came to you with meat most of the time
I'll slice meat and put Kimchi on it.
And if the two of them together don't,
people bury that shit like in their
backyard.
Koreans do.
Yeah.
They make a pot and it ferments and the
bird in their bag,
it's really good for your gut
microbiome.
And the more we find out about that,
that's why I was saying like what I'm
doing is an intervention.
I'm not going to just eat meat forever.
Right.
Um,
because I,
the next,
the next step for me is once I get to
the point where I feel like I'm lean
enough to where I want to be,
I still want to lose about 10 pounds.
And you really,
yeah,
I get leaner.
You lean still have a lot of belly fat
that's been around from my drinking
everyday for so the upper abs come in,
but then the lower abs is still,
uh,
you know,
so we got out,
we had tightened.
I shut up.
Other than Peter Luger going off the
rails,
I've been on a strict diet for two weeks
and I've lost five pounds.
What's your diet?
Which you just meat and vegetables.
That's mostly it.
And any sort of a rhyme or reason or you
just eat as much as you want when you
want or,
I got a little fat.
I got up to about 200 and that's what
I'm fat and I,
I like to be like right now I was one 94
after my run.
Some probably like one 96.
It's amazing.
We weighed the same exact weight one 94
this morning.
Yeah.
Just became best friends.
Ah,
did we just become,
yeah,
I like to be,
I think if I'm really,
if I'm shredded,
I'm down at about one 90.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
I'm really,
so I think I need,
I could lose another four pounds.
I think being mindful as a key factor,
you know that you're like I'm getting
fat.
Hold yourself to a standard.
I tell people all the time try to be
made as something different.
Yeah.
The only way I know how to like build
up,
uh,
any self esteem or you know,
build up self respect or any of these
things is through training or through
diet.
I can't really do it through a business
meeting.
I can't do it just through like reading
a book.
You can get motivated by watching a
youtube video or something,
but that lasts you a couple hours.
Maybe it lasts you for the week.
Maybe it helps point in the right
direction,
which is cool.
Well the thing about it for martial
arts,
especially for striking is when you lose
weight,
you move faster.
It's like if I,
if I went out there and hit the bag and
I put a 40 pound weight vest on,
strap that fucker and I would feel
slower.
I mean I just would,
I just,
there's no way around it.
Well,
even 10 pounds makes a difference.
When I used to fight,
one of the things that I noticed when I
would get down close to my weight class
is I just move quicker because I was
carrying around less weight.
I felt,
I felt like I was less to move around.
Like my muscles are essentially as
strong and probably lost a little bit of
muscle when you lose weight,
but most of it was there,
but my body fat on my body weight was
down several pounds and I would just
move quicker.
You used to be tough as a fighter to
gauge that too though.
Like when you lose too much,
like maybe like one almost wanting to
avoid food to feel faster.
You.
You see that with a lot of UFC fighters
when they get down too low in weight,
they just can't perform properly and
this,
that,
and I think there's a real issue with
MMA and that issue is there's not enough
weight classes.
I,
they're very,
very strongly about this.
I think there's giant gaps like one 85
to two oh five drives me fucking crazy.
It's a 20 that's a gap.
That's a tough area to,
because guys can be so muscular that
way,
or skinny I it does it.
Well,
it's really how tall they are,
whatever.
But it's really like what is your
optimal and the idea that people would
fit in between that 20 pounds optimal
either this way or that way.
It's crazy because those two oh five
guys,
a lot of them could be heavyweights like
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones could be the heavyweight
champion of the world.
100% no doubt about it,
no fucking doubt about it.
Yet.
He's still in ways two oh five when he
fights and he doesn't have a hard time
making that weight.
Now if you're a guy like say Hector
Lombard,
who's fought at one 70 and just really
packs a lot of meat on,
and he fights it one 85 you know it,
when he fights at one 85 he could,
he's also fought at two oh five before I
believe if he decided to fight it one at
two Oh five and John Jones decides to
fight it to a five I mean hector's my
height and Jon Jones towers over me.
So you're looking at just a totally
different body size and totally
different frame that 20 pounds is too
much man.
And then from two oh five to
heavyweight,
you could get some brock Lesnar
motherfucker that or Francis and Ghana
who has to cut weight to make two 65
frances even more impressive.
Right,
because he's natural.
I mean,
he's not even barely lifting weights.
I mean that guy is just a fucking
gigantic super athlete.
So that guy doesn't really lift.
No,
it's huge.
Huge.
He got that big from working in a
fucking sand mine.
Oh my God,
this is,
I mean,
he literally is like Conan the barbarian
from the Robert E.
Howard Nigerian.
He is from Cameroon I believe.
Right?
I think that's where he's from.
He,
there's videos of him on his instagram
from yesterday of him back in the same
sand mine and he's wearing his fucking
Reebok Jersey with his name on the back
of it,
digging sand with all the guys who used
to work with.
It's fucking crazy.
But that is hard labor and it's,
there it is.
Do that all day.
Dig fucking stand all day.
You know how fucking strong you had been
just carrying 20 pound hunks of sand and
shoving them into the top of that truck
all day long.
He's a beast.
Well he's uh,
he's got tremendous genetics.
His father has built a chem two.
There's a picture of him on his
instagram when he was three years old
standing next to his father and you look
at his daddy like,
oh Jesus,
like the apple on the tree.
They are baby.
You think he's going to be pretty
dangerous coming up?
Like the only issue with Francis,
his wrestling and his uh,
in his endurance,
and this is just based on his fight with
steep emile chick who in my opinion is
the best heavy weight ever.
I think if you look at what Steve Pays
managed to do in his career,
uh,
he's defended the title more than
anybody.
He knocked out for breezy over Dune was
one of the best ever.
He knocked out Alistair Overeem,
he beat Francis and Ghana who everybody
was fucking terrified of and Francis
been blowing everybody out of the water,
including Alistair overeem.
I just think and knocked out junior dos
Santos,
also former heavyweight champion.
I think Steve pays the best of all time.
So when you know,
Steve [inaudible] is able to beat you
and beat you by using his wrestling and
using his smarts and using his,
his octagon intelligence and just his
overall fight Iq,
he just knows how to fight better.
He's just got more tools in the toolbox.
Frances can learn and he's an incredible
athlete and what he has over everybody,
his power,
he has more power in his punch.
We have a machine out there called the
power cube and that machine Francis
registered the highest ever power punch
by like 10,000 units,
whatever the fuck that means.
So tyrone spong,
who's a super powerful heavyweight
boxer,
he scored like one 19 I think it was an
f or one 14 and then Francis scored
1209209000 and you see it when he hits
people.
And that's about what you kick,
right?
You get your check a little bit more
than that.
So that's,
I kicked in the face.
I hold the record right now until
somebody beats ago.
We'll hold the red one 5,252 from a
kick.
That's,
but again,
look at the size of my leg,
like carrying around 196 pounds all day,
running hills with 196 pounds.
Try,
try doing fucking handstands and running
up a hill with handstands.
You just can't,
you're arms are not that strong.
And also,
you know,
I've been kicking my whole life,
he's really only been training him in
Maine for five years.
Yeah.
So he's just,
he's fun to watch.
He's amazing to watch.
It's like a old Tyson fight.
Yeah.
Even the match,
even a fight with us.
Steve Bay was kind of scary cause he
just kept getting back up and it was
like,
it was like watching now Mike Myers like
a horror movie or something.
Michael Myers and,
or Freddy Kruger or something just kept
coming back.
It doesn't have the wrestling
experience.
It doesn't have the wrestling technique.
But what he has is a incredible heart
and desire and he's very hungry to
learn.
And I'm,
I'm very hopeful that he's going to
learn and you know,
and I really,
really hope that he incorporates,
um,
of real rigorous wrestling program
because that was one thing that was
lacking from his last,
uh,
it was the last training camp when he
fought for steep pen.
I think you have seen needs a 300 and up
club,
I think.
So,
you know,
to have that,
have that weight class and then have him
only fight for a minute and rest for
like five minutes.
Well there's nothing I issue is there's
not enough fighters.
There's not enough guys,
you know,
but not enough big boys.
Yeah.
Maybe you just like put,
you saw it on the back burner for up to
65 and I'm going to do whatever you
want.
Um,
you know,
uh,
I'm,
I'm hopeful that Francis still,
I mean,
he's a little older in terms of like
being this new to the sport at 33,
you know,
I mean,
it really didn't even start training
until he was 28.
I mean,
he's kind of crazy.
He was homeless.
Yeah.
I mean,
you want to talk about our amazing story
that's like right out of a movie.
The guy was homeless,
came from Africa where he worked in a
fucking sand mine and then gets to the
number one contender spot in the UFC.
But there's guys now,
uh,
like,
um,
Alexander Volkov is that Volcom Volkov
cough.
Um,
the guy who just knocked out,
um,
February over doom.
He's this,
this is a giant guy.
Like he's a huge,
I think he's six,
seven cheese.
Yeah.
And incredibly skillful.
So there's,
there's these guys that are coming up
that are like at the higher end of the
way class.
How do you say his last name?
Volkov right.
I W I always get confused because
Russians say things with Russian accent.
I was under the vocal vocal Volkov is
find out if that's the case,
if he that tall.
He is,
he's six,
seven,
yeah.
He's a incredibly long and efficient and
he has real power.
He,
and he's hard to hit man,
but his game is so well rounded.
The difference between him and a guy
likes,
you know,
um,
uh,
Francis is,
he's not new to the game.
I mean he's a giant guy who's been
fighting for a long fucking time,
so he is a real efficient martial
artists.
When he fought Fabrizio Verdon I could
tell early on the striking exchanges
like,
wow,
fabrizio might be in trouble.
Like this guy is,
he's long,
he knows that the stay on the outside
and he knows he's got an excellent sense
of distance and he's got legit knockout
power and he fucked fabrizio up,
man.
That was,
that was hard to watch.
I was like,
wow,
this guy's,
he's legit.
It's amazing.
These longer body types have been so
good.
Anderson Silva Bounce Jones.
Yeah.
A lot of these guys have,
you know,
you wouldn't think that,
you'd think someone may be shorter
stockier and getting the inside.
But did he seize up long?
Seems like a huge beat Saturday night.
Sharapov say that five times fast.
Like I said,
well before we came on the podcast,
as soon as he came on,
I'm going six to one 45 you can find a
skinnier guy I thought.
And then I saw him fight and man,
he was just so impressive.
But fast and strong live at one 45 and
six two I guess voice was,
you know,
he wasn't real tall but he was like six
one right.
But he was one 75 mm.
And you know,
he was obviously fighting in the
unlimited class and he was fighting guys
like Dan Severn at the time.
It was two 65 feet is thin,
but he's got muscle on him if he's kind
of jacked.
Like when you looked at it like a
perfect frame.
He's all almost awesome,
a little tiny luke rockhold and a lot of
ways,
but with a way more dynamic game.
He could do everything.
That guy,
he was really interesting to watch this
first time I ever saw him.
Fight Dot guy is fucking phenomenal.
He's so talented.
That was the first time I saw him fight
live and it's a different thing when you
see someone live.
Like if you see someone in a video and
you go,
wow,
that guy's good.
But they,
you see him live and you know your brain
has like a little computer where it's
seen or you know you've got,
they've got a database,
especially me,
I've seen so many fights,
have a database of how people move and
then you see that guy moving.
You're like,
Whoa,
what are we looking at here?
Because I love seeing that.
I love seeing this next level shit,
that next level thing.
Like whether it's you know,
connor or whether it's a tyron woodley
or these,
every now and then you see next level
and you go,
oh,
like tyron woodley to me.
He fought Carlos condit and there was a
moment in the condit fight where he
stepped forward and snap Carlos with a a
straight right hand.
I was like,
Whoa,
that's like 10% faster than it should
be.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
you get used to world class athletes
moving and then you see someone like
Edson Barboza switch kick.
That's another one.
You're like,
Whoa,
whoa baby.
You know.
But to me the biggest example that is
Nurburg of madoff's wrestling Khabib
takes how,
my God,
everybody,
everybody who's good,
how failed though?
Just Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
black belt,
world champion,
rag dolls,
everybody,
Michael Johnson.
I mean,
no matter who he fights,
he ragdolled this guy in the beginning
and I thought it was over right away.
I was like,
oh,
this is over and that.
But I can't say did,
did really well,
did very well.
Very well.
The thing about higher quinta is he's a
legit crazy person.
Like that guy's crazy.
He trashes hotel rooms.
He's like,
you look at his eyes like,
oh,
there's only like a's,
the guy,
a couple of people home.
It's not a full village in that head.
That's not a good example.
But what I'm saying like he's a legit
maniac and he's not scared.
Like he'll fight anybody.
Like you could wake him up at three
o'clock in the morning and he'll fight.
Anybody made crazy thing.
He was screaming.
He was running around the hotel lobby
the day when,
when we found out Max Holloway could not
make weight.
And the new,
by the way,
I shouldn't say could not make weight.
I believe Max would have made the way
they did in New York State Athletic
Commission,
which they made some,
they made some big errors and I can go
into detail with a couple of them.
One of them is they wouldn't let Paul
felder fight.
Um,
Paul felder wanted to fight.
They said he's not ranked.
Paul felder is a fucking killer.
He is a straight up killer.
And him versus Khabib would have been a
very interesting fight because Paul is a
big one 55.
He's very big and very strong and he is
an expert world class striker.
I mean Paul felder is a dangerous,
dangerous man for anybody.
In 155 pounds and he's a grounded pound
expert.
He's also get very good defense in,
in everything.
Very good defense,
standing up.
Very good defense on the ground.
He felt his fucking well rounded.
I would have been very intrigued in that
fight and they offered it to felder fell
this had fuck.
Yeah.
And then in Nevada state or the,
excuse me,
New York State Athletic Commission said,
I was like,
you guys are out of your fucking minds.
You don't know shit about fighting if
you don't think that guy could fight for
the title because Paul might be fighting
for the title in a year from now or
whenever.
I mean he's fucking world class.
So the fact that they don't know that
and they're saying,
well,
based on the rankings,
the rankings are horse shit.
They're arbitrary.
They're made by a bunch of people that I
think a lot of times they're biased.
They have terrible judgment.
Sometimes the guy will fuck a guy up and
then you look at the rankings and he's
below that guy.
He just fucked up in the rankings.
Explain that there was no other way to
tell if a guy's better than who we
fucked up.
And they say,
wow,
it was past experience suck fat dicks.
That past experience doesn't mean
anything.
This guy just date,
this guy beat the guy who beat the guy.
That guy beat him.
Well if he was number one,
now he's number one.
That's how it goes.
You can't get knocked out and still be
number one.
That's fucking bananas.
And this is often the case when you see
a guy beat a guy and he's still below
the guy in the rank.
He's like,
what the fuck else can he do?
How did you end up with the guy?
How did they end up getting I
acquainted?
Then they just asked him.
He was in,
he was the next guy in line.
He's on a four or five fight win streak.
Um,
and he's beaten some very good guys like
Jorge Mosfet doll,
uh,
Ross Pearson.
He's beaten some legit guys.
I mean,
look,
I Quinta can bang and he's tough as shit
and he's got a wrestling background,
which I think played a big factor in
that fight.
Obviously he was greatly outclass by a
guy who I think is one of the greatest
lightweight of all time.
And now that he's the champion,
I'm very interested in seeing.
But I think what,
what we saw in that fight that was very
intriguing was the fact that I acquaint
it was able to get back up and that I
quit was one of the few guys that number
go madoff has ever fought,
that has stuffed a bunch of take downs
and then into the late rounds.
And this is a guy in owl that didn't
even prepare for a five round fight.
He was getting ready for a three round
fight with Paul felder.
So I mean fucking props to ally La
Quinta.
I mean fucking animal.
Great job.
I was off animal and major props to the
could that Kyle Bochniac kit that
[inaudible] beat that kid and savage
cause he ate everything.
He was smiling,
punched in the face,
smiling and coming off the end of the
fight and the three rounds of a clinic,
I mean he's a beat put on a clinic.
He did everything,
jumped,
spinning back kicks,
roundhouse tricks,
switch kicks.
He hit him with a switch kick.
There was like Jesus Bochniac took a
couple to the neck rack and still kept
calm and still kept common blood coming
out of his nose,
his mouth stickin Freemason,
sticking his tongue out on him.
And then as a beat,
it's like,
what the fuck do I got to do to this
guy?
At the end of it blocked me,
acts,
got him pinned up against the cage and
he's throwing bombs and was crazy.
The whole place.
The entire Barclay Center on their feet.
Fuck.
I stood up,
I was screaming and cop and it was
phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
That's what I love,
you know.
And that was in my mind,
that was worth the price of admission
for the whole paper with your car,
just to see who's the best fight for
sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
But to see our do that just shows you
that,
you know,
Al is a legit worldclass fighter.
You mean?
Definitely is not on the level of could
be,
but nobody thought he was coming in.
I think it was,
uh,
in a lot of ways an upset,
just the fact that he was able to go to
the distance and you see what could be
did to so many other fighters mean he
mall different else and he mauled out
for a lot of the fight.
I mean,
look,
the guy's the best wrestler at one 55
ever.
I mean,
He does things to worldclass guys that
makes you just confused because he's
not,
it's like there's certain guys that are
doing things like ya year Rodriguez is a
perfect example.
He does wild shit.
He does like jump three 60 roundhouse
kicks.
He threesixty roundhouse kicks Bj Penn
and the fate and you're like,
what the fuck?
So this is like a guy doing something to
the other guy with the other guy.
Just can't do that.
He can't move that way.
Number of Madoff is doing standard
stuff,
but he's doing it at such a high level
that he'd makes world class fighters,
questioned their career.
He takes them in malls,
them and they have a different sense of
where they fit in the universe.
It's crazy to see somebody come back
from that when they're getting the shit
beat out of them.
They're getting hit so hard.
You're like,
what makes you,
and I've had,
I've had some fighters and stuff that,
that I've talked to you in the past and
a lot of times they don't even know that
how fucking bat shit crazy they are.
I did pro wrestling for for a handful of
years and when I was wrestling,
a lot of times we'd share the ring and
so on and a lot of times like the UFC
fighters,
they would say,
you guys are fucking crazy.
What are you guys doing in there?
Fucking jumping off the top rope.
I'm like,
we're crazy with the fit.
You're doing fucking out of this world.
Well,
I've goofed around about pro wrestling
before,
but my honest feelings,
all,
all bullshit aside.
This is one of the toughest professions
in all of entertainer.
Udl.
It is unbelievably.
It is gay though.
That's why I was in it just for the gay
style.
Exactly.
It's not,
you know,
it's,
it's not a sport,
it's entertainment,
but you have to be incredibly athletic
to do some shit they do.
And the beating those guys take this in
terms of their body,
it's,
it's very underappreciated cause you
just watch it and you go,
oh,
it's not real.
They're not really fighting.
But no,
they're really hitting each other with
chairs.
They're really jumping off the top rope.
It's slamming each other.
I mean all the crazy shit that they do,
the,
the toll those guys take on their body
is an unbearable,
like what we're saying about Kurt Angle,
like that guy has gone through a fuck
load.
I mean,
see if you can find that picture.
I think it's on Ronda Rousey's instagram
page.
Ronda Rousey with Kurt Angle at the end
of their match and you're looking at it
50 he won Olympic gold medal with a
broken neck and he's still going to be a
gold medal with his neck was broken.
Then he won the Olympics.
Brogan freaking night,
not like broken in half.
It was fractured.
He had a fracture in his neck and he's
still one.
What the fuck down.
It wasn't supposed to restaurant.
No,
no,
no.
Not that.
That was a good one.
But the one with the arms raised,
is it on hers?
Maybe it's not.
There it is right there.
Look at that.
Look at his arms,
man.
Yeah,
that's your feed.
Yeah.
Look at that left arm.
I mean that's crazy.
It looks like,
no,
no offense Jamie.
It looks like Jamie's arm.
Jim,
you've got big arms.
You do have big arms.
I mean you do,
but you have big arms for a normal guy.
He's a god.
Go Gorilla.
Normal.
Yeah,
for normal.
Well your your athletic,
but your guy.
I'm not saying anything bad,
but I'm saying that for the size of what
he used to look like.
Go back.
Look at the size of his fucking neck,
dude.
What is that thing right below his ear?
What is that?
That's his neck.
That's your fucking,
that's like,
I just gotta go for living in his neck.
You know the way those guys train their
neck is crazy.
The way that dude's with bridges and
shit and then that's just not good for
you man.
I don't think so.
But there's an article about that
recently where they were describing like
the dangers of neck bridging.
You know,
he does strengthen your neck.
Well wrestling,
they do a lot of shit that's not great
for you.
I don't think rightly,
it's kind of part of the par for the
course.
Right.
With collegiate style wrestling.
Do you ever fuck with that iron neck?
I like it.
Yeah.
I love that.
I like it.
I love that they use it for some dead
lifts the other day and I felt I felt
stronger,
legitimately felt stronger.
Oh,
it's phenomenal.
I actually used it and didn't know that
I had an issue with my neck until I used
it and then after I used it,
um,
wait a second,
I can turn my head all the way now.
So I think it's great.
One of the things about it is the range
of motion that it gives you and for
grapplers I think it is mandatory.
I think it would,
it's a mandatory thing for,
I fucked my neck up for a bunch of
reasons.
One,
from being an idiot and not tapping to
from getting injured and still training,
but three,
because one of my biggest moves is the
arm triangle.
So in the arm triangle when you grow,
get a head and arm choke.
When I got the art guys arm trapped
here,
I'm using my neck,
so I'm constantly like pinning things
down with my neck and you know,
you're rolling for a fucking hour a
night or whatever it is.
It's a lot of pressure you're putting on
your neck and then defending things with
your neck and everything gets inflamed
and everything's injured and you get
these little micro injuries that never
really heal because you're back training
again.
Yeah,
the iron neck thing works great to,
I think we both looked at it kind of
skeptical when we first saw it and then
the guy did a demo for us and we both
used it and thought it was really cool.
And you put on this from your helmet.
It looks weird and I ended up beginning,
you're,
you're like,
what is this thing?
You know?
And then it works great.
But I mean,
even one of those harnesses with a
weight,
just anything where you're,
you know,
just constantly conditioning your neck
and your neck needs workout.
It really does.
It's when you know you're serious about
trainings when you have a fucking neck
harness.
Yeah man.
Yeah.
I've always had that one back in the
day.
I'm a big believer in working out your
neck,
you know,
and John Jacques Machado,
my Jujitsu instructor is a very famous
quote.
He says,
never trust your neck.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Never Trust your neck.
You know,
like if you think that you'll see,
you know,
if someone's choking you,
it's like,
don't just think that your neck is
strong enough to handle it.
Fuck that.
Protect your neck.
Yeah.
Kurt Angle looks like he's got over 20
inch neck or something.
I mean,
it's cute.
It looks like he's pushing his head off
his fucking shoulders.
It's,
yeah,
it's like two of my thighs holding his
fucking head up.
But I mean,
it's probably just to support his neck
with all the injuries of the guys had.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure he's got fused disks or
something going on up there,
right?
Yeah.
He got,
he had surgery a couple of times.
He said,
yeah,
actually,
um,
you know,
he was addicted to drugs.
Now he's doing a big thing,
um,
on sobriety.
And,
uh,
he was,
um,
heavily addicted to like opioids for a
long time and he actually got us our,
he actually went to the point where,
um,
I believe it was a situation where it
was either the drugs or he gets fired
and he basically got fired from ww or
released or is con,
you know,
whatever,
whatever happened.
But I'm sort of went down a really bad
road and it's as good to see him back
and be held back being like,
as you know,
as healthy as he can be at this point
because,
uh,
he went through a really rough time.
You know,
I loved your documentary prescription
thugs,
and I've shown it and recommended it to
so many people.
I just think we live in a crazy time.
You're,
you're hearing all the time someone's
cousin and my brother or this guy,
my mom,
people get injured,
they get on pills and then they wind up
dying or they go down that road and they
become addicts.
Yeah.
It's,
it is a fucking,
not so silent but epidemic in this
country.
And a lot of people feel completely
helpless because they're getting
prescribed these things by their doctor,
so they think they should take them.
And then,
you know,
you watch your friend drift away.
I mean,
it happened to one of my family members.
I watched my family member go from being
an,
a normal guy to being a total fucking
loser.
And it's just because he hurt his back
and he got hooked on pills and the next
thing you can't keep a job.
And he's always on the pills.
And he never did shit when I knew him,
I grew up with this kid.
He was totally normal and now he's all
fucked up and it's just,
is he still messed up?
Yeah,
I still fucked up.
He doesn't want to get sober.
I can't,
I don't know.
Do you know when you're a kid,
you can't hold someone's hand?
You can't.
I mean,
he lives in Boston.
I can't fly to Boston and fucking holds
his hand
sharing that.
We have,
we have a cousin who's an alcoholic and,
um,
and he's in his thirties,
you know,
he needs a liver transplant and,
oh,
and you still goes and drinks in this
fucking thirties.
Yeah.
And,
um,
damn,
you know,
and it's just a shame because we love
him and he's our cousin,
but there's nothing that we can do to
help him.
I've tried to help him so many times,
even oftener offering to
bring them out here to go to Rehab for
free,
um,
because of the people I know.
And um,
he didn't take me up on it and I,
that kind of thing is crazy and we lost
our uncle,
we lost her brother to from this kind of
thing.
And it's brutal.
Brutal.
It runs rampant.
It does.
And it's so easy for people to get lost.
I mean,
Shab Shab broke his nose and the cro,
cop,
cro,
cop smashed his nose with an elbow and
he had to get his nose reconstructed.
And when he got his nose reconstruct
that they put him on pills and next
thing you know he's taking those pills
all day long and it's four months later.
And his buddies grabbed him and they
went to his house and they,
they,
they opened up as medicine cabinet,
they threw everything away and they go,
this is it.
It's over.
You're not doing this anymore,
man.
Fuck.
And he's like,
you're right,
you're right.
And you went cold Turkey.
Yeah.
And Luckily Brendan is a strong guy
mentally.
And he got off of it and that was it.
And he likes to talk about it cause
it's,
it's an important thing because he goes,
I would have never thought that I would
get addicted to drugs.
It's such a sickness.
I remember the last,
the last time I did Percocet,
uh,
was at a UCLA USC game and I took a
bunch of cars.
I was like,
I'm going to be sitting through this
game the whole time.
I'll take the whole bottle.
I took 30 of them with me to this game.
30 30 pills.
What do you mean with me to this game?
This is even gets even better.
I sit down in my seat and right behind
me is the doctor who runs the,
who owns the clinic where I got my
surgery done and meanwhile I'm high like
super high talking to this doctor the
whole time on the pills that he
prescribed it to me.
You know,
I did 30 pills during that game,
you know,
I,
that's crazy.
Did the doctor know that you're pilled
up?
I mean he would had to know.
I mean,
I don't know,
but it's kind of like it was,
we,
it was a weird situation,
but um,
you know,
getting,
getting off those pills was,
was necessary.
It would have ended my life for sure.
Now,
if you had gotten a surgery tomorrow,
let's say,
what if your,
your hip fucked up and they had to go
back and Redo it?
Would you take the pain pills?
I would do,
I would take the painkillers that as
long as I was in the hospital,
like whatever,
whatever I'm supervised.
Would you be scared though,
that you would now jump right back in?
I don't think it works that way.
You know,
like I,
I don't,
I don't think it'd be,
you know,
a trigger.
Um,
but I wouldn't take them at home.
I'd use Kratom or something else.
And who knows?
I don't know how good kratom would work
after a surgery.
Right,
right,
right.
We don't know how it works at them.
Did help you write,
helps me phenomenally.
Every single day.
Yeah.
My friend cams on that stuff too.
He was a,
he had a real problem with Ibuprofen for
awhile.
And then Doctor Rhonda Patrick did a
podcast with me where she was talking
about the dangers of Ibuprofen and all
the different real severe side effects
that people have from real injury.
Your Gut microbiome,
it ruins your libido and your,
um,
your sperm count too.
Well,
this is the,
the gut microbiome was really
fascinating because it causes
inflammation and he was dealing with
inflammation issues.
So He'd wake up,
his hips would hurt,
his feet would hurt,
his knees would hurt.
So He'd take 800 milligrams of
Ibuprofen.
He would do it several times a day.
That's what I was doing.
But it was a cycle.
So that was what was causing the
inflammation because it was fucked up as
gut microbiome.
So he gets off of it and then in,
then he calls me and he's like,
you can't fucking believe this man.
He goes,
I'm off in all,
my pain's gone.
He kept running because he's an animal.
So he,
he said it's,
the pain's gone.
He's like,
the pain was being caused by the
inflammation that was caused by
Ibuprofen,
like holy fucking shit.
And he just thanked me.
He's like,
if it wasn't for Rhonda,
Patrick,
I,
you know who not mean people get
strokes.
They have all sorts of funny,
right?
You're not supposed to take that.
I mean,
it's fine if you take it.
I go,
I have a headache.
Take a little Ibuprofen.
You'll be fine.
It's not going to kill you.
But if you take that shit,
800 milligrams a day for a couple of
years,
who the fuck knows what's going to do to
you?
Your body is not designed for
nonsteroidal antiinflammatories on a
daily basis,
on very high doses over and over and
over combined,
you know,
the advil,
Ibuprofen and the Acetaminophen that it
works even better.
So that's what I was doing.
I would take about eight advil a day and
eight tylenol a day.
So I'm killing not only my liver,
but my kidneys also.
And you know,
I've known a lot of people that have had
transplants because of that.
Um,
have a kidney transplant because they're
taking too much ibuprofen now.
Um,
your documentary,
a leaf of faith,
you still doing that?
We finished it.
Yeah.
It comes out on,
on May 29th and that's all about Kratom.
Yeah,
it's all about Kratom.
It's sort of a,
it's really about my experience with
Kratom.
It's about my journey,
you know,
like,
Hey,
I was this guy who lifted weights and
did all these things and got hurt and
this is what happened to me.
And I just,
I sort of tell the story and then as I
tell the story,
I go out and discover,
you know,
is Kratom good or bad for you?
And we talked to,
we talked to both sides of the issue.
We talked to the Congress people that
are trying to ban it.
We talked to the ones that are trying to
save it and well,
they're calling it an opiate now.
Yeah.
They call it,
they definitely call it.
It was a real recent,
those are recent redefinition of the
show that you and I did.
Um,
and in the movie you'll see it.
It's very pivotal.
Like what you do is awesome with this
podcast,
by the way.
But what we,
what we were able to do from that show
is like basically you kept Kratom legal,
uh,
without even knowing it.
So we did the podcast and then after the
podcast,
at the end of the podcast,
he said,
hey,
if anybody wants to help,
where can they go?
And I said,
they'd go on this website and they leave
comments for the Dea will 23,000 people
or maybe 24,000 people.
I can't remember left comments after
your podcast.
That's amazing.
The Dea said,
Whoa,
wait a second.
We can't make this illegal.
There's people go crazy.
But what did they do recently?
They definitely classified,
it's totally illegal.
That was the FDA,
not the dea.
The FDA came out.
And,
um,
because,
okay,
so here's why really this why calls
creative and opioid and warrants against
using this up.
And I'll tell you why.
It's because hunts,
uh,
no,
not at all.
I like that the FDA is doing the right
thing here.
What?
Yup.
Dare you.
Uh,
I'll tell you what have you done with
Chris?
I'll tell you why.
A lot of people are marketing Kratom the
wrong way.
They're packaging it the wrong way and
they are not testing it.
And when they're not testing it,
you have things like a salmonella
outbreak.
I heard about that.
That hurt,
you know,
put 28 people or something in the
hospital.
So I forget how many people,
but there was a salmonella outbreak and
that's because a company buys Kratom
from overseas,
from like Indonesia.
They get it shipped here and they don't
test it for contaminants,
you know.
So the company that I did the film with
a company called urban ice,
they test all the products for
contaminants three times during the
process.
You know,
you own a supplement company,
you know how it works.
You have to test your shit
independently.
It's very important day party,
independent testing.
And that's what people aren't doing.
And so they're trying to make,
so they make it cheaper,
you know,
and then the companies that are doing
it,
that screws them because now they got to
try to make their product cheaper to
keep up with other people.
But they're paying for the testing each
time.
Well,
the supplement business is almost on the
honor system.
You know,
it's,
it's really,
it's really crazy.
My friend Aubrey,
whom I'm partners with an on it and uh,
he was explaining to me how those big
Dick pills work.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
when you buy them at the gas station and
the hard on pills,
he's like those pills,
most of them have cialis or Viagra and
I'm,
yeah.
And so they get busted.
Somebody bust some and then once they
bust them,
they go,
oh,
sorry.
They changed the name of the company,
they sell it again and then they get
busted again.
And they just keep doing this because
there's a little shuffle.
We're in the same thing with the Kratom
industry based on,
so what else
Susan Kratom like if you buy Kratom
somewhere,
what could it possibly be other than,
uh,
well,
so there's this,
that happens sometimes.
Yeah.
And there's different acts actually
happened in Sweden to the point where
people died.
So in Sweden,
uh,
they put fentanyl in with Kratom's
Christ and nine nine people died.
And I don't want to scare people off of
a have taken it because I use it every
day.
Well,
the spray company that you use,
because that was the guy that's brought
on the podcast,
but Nice organics,
that company have an ice organics.
Yeah.
And that stuff I've used and it's great.
That their website's natural organics
with an x on the end.com.
What's interesting to me too is that in
low doses,
it's actually kind of a stimulant.
Almost like a cup of coffee.
Yeah.
Burden,
high doses.
It's more relaxing.
Yeah.
Do you take it?
I take it occasionally.
Yeah.
We have some in the back.
Yeah,
yeah.
You did.
Yeah.
And I thought,
ah,
because you know,
the thing is that,
um,
not everybody is in pain,
but a lot of people feel stress.
Stress is a big deal,
you know,
and um,
Kratom really helps people with anxiety,
ptsd.
If someone has anxiety,
like how many pills did they take for
anxiety?
But see I take two at a time.
I think that's the problem we're getting
into.
I can't really tell people that stuff
cause that's like illegal according to
the FDA now I can because I'm a film
maker.
Right,
right.
Um,
so I would say take two.
But um,
for the most part,
like a company can't tell you that like
a,
you know,
you as the owner of onnit can't say take
this many pills and this whole like take
this much alpha brain and it'll do this
for your brain.
Cause you,
you say the wrong thing and the FDA's
all over your ass.
Right.
So that's,
that's an issue.
Um,
like the way that the way that Kratom
needs to be marketed is like basically
the way that supplements are supposed to
be marketed is,
you know,
that you're taking it for a specific
response
and the FDA doesn't let you tell people
that,
which is just really screwed up too.
Because I think that that's a problem.
It's like an issue.
You know,
like you should be able to say what it
does.
The problem is people make way too many
health claims.
So with Kratom they make the health
claim that it will cure opioid addiction
and that's a huge claim to make.
And um,
it's a ridiculous claim to make.
It can help somebody get over an opioid
addiction,
but to say it cures and opioid addiction
or to say that it,
uh,
even even will cure your pain or help
your pain.
Those are bigger claims then supplements
are allowed to make.
And that's the issue with people coming
down on it.
But is the thing like what helps you
over an addiction?
There's so many factors.
First of all,
there's genetics.
Some people have a genetic propensity
for addiction.
It's just the fact that runs in their
family.
And I don't know if that's nature and
nurture,
but cause I don't have it in my family,
but some people do.
I know people that they drink one drink
and they get fucking job and they're off
to the races.
There was gone,
they disappear.
You know,
people like that.
Right.
Yeah.
And there was a big difference.
My Dad says there was a big difference
between our brother Mike and and me and
the way that we did it.
So I sort of fell into it.
But Mike was kind of always that way.
You fell into it because of surgery
because surgery and constant pain
because if you have,
Mike fell into it cause he was a
osteoarthritis arthritis,
our brother mad dog,
he fell into it because he was animal.
He just,
he was always that guy.
Yeah,
he was,
you know,
the guy who's like the king of the
school ahead of everything.
That was mad dog.
He was always,
you know,
always in charge.
Always had the most friends,
was super popular,
you know.
But there was something,
some void inside,
something missing that would turn them
to drugs and alcohol.
Man.
It's like when you know someone that has
that,
it is such a helpless feeling because
there's not a goddamn thing you can do
about it.
I first experienced it when I was in
high school.
Um,
my dad was an architect and a,
I got a lot of gigs over the summer
working on construction sites and so I
would hang out with a lot of these guys
that were carpenters and laborers and
this one guy that I've worked with is a
great guy,
but he couldn't fucking lay off the
coke.
Yeah,
couldn't,
he would get clean.
He was like,
this is it.
I'm getting my band together.
I'd be like,
that's awesome man.
Good for you.
And then he would come in,
hung over,
fucked up like it just looks like he had
the flu and it's dark.
It's dark and it's dark and stop.
You keep going back to it.
I used to go in my bathroom in the
morning hungover every day,
look in the mirror and go,
who the fuck are you?
Like what is that fat gross wrinkly old
dude doing in the mirror?
Like what happened to you?
You're,
you're a movie was 96% on rotten
tomatoes about,
about steroids and,
and health and,
and trying to figure out if this is good
or bad for you and now you're just a
fucked up drug addict.
And I would just cry.
And I had nothing like nowhere to turn.
I felt like I couldn't tell my parents
because they just experienced it.
I felt like I couldn't tell my brother
cause he's in the fitness and training
and he's going to be like,
come on dude,
snap out of it.
You know how that's possible.
It's what I,
it's what I thought.
But what I thought didn't happen as soon
as mark found out about it,
he said,
come here,
give me a big hug and say,
well,
we're going to help you.
You know?
And,
and I think that's most people's fear is
that it's going to be really bad.
But I should tell everybody it's going
to be really,
really good when you come out.
That other side of wife was a big part
of it and the advice I always give and
we try to always give is just don't give
up on people.
You can't,
you,
you don't want to overextend yourself
because you are going to get fucked over
by people that are addicts.
You will get screwed over.
Um,
but you just tell him,
hey,
whenever you're ready,
I'm here to help.
Whatever way I can help.
If I can help financially,
if I can help,
uh,
you know,
whatever way I can help,
I'm here to help.
Just let them know.
And then that way you can always at
least feel good that you,
you at least did some of your part there
in with him,
my wife was like,
we got to get him the hell out of Los
Angeles.
We live in Sacramento.
She's like,
we got to get them up here.
So we flew him up just so you can keep
an eye on them.
Not that Sacramento is not without its
temptation.
That's a hundred,
a hundred percent.
Just a not be on his own was the main
thing is he doesn't have any family down
here and stuff.
And so we did that and took him under is
under our wing and um,
you know,
got him lifting and the Diet.
I think everything,
I think everything helped get them to
where he is now.
I'm so proud of him.
It's unbelievable.
The sounds kind of Dorky,
you know,
in some way.
Cause he's my bro folks.
We're supposed to talk shit about each
other all the time,
you know,
but I am really proud of him and he's
been an idol of mine sent,
you know,
since I was a little kid.
He's the reason why I lift.
He's in reason why I laughed so hard and
he'll get motivated by me and he'll say,
dude,
I saw you doing that crazy shit.
He's like,
I'm going to go in and dead lift.
But it's really him that's motivating
me.
He's the driver of a lot of this.
Well,
um,
you've,
you really do look a lot healthier than
when I first,
I think it looks,
it's fucking awesome.
Thanks for both.
I'm getting showered and prays over
while I was like,
you look good man.
Thank you man.
I really appreciate it.
Someone you see them,
they just look vibrant.
You know,
you can tell when someone's healthy.
That's all.
I first started getting sober.
It was hard,
you know,
he,
he was losing weight,
he was doing everything,
you know,
he's doing everything good,
but he still was getting sick all the
time and he looked sickly,
you know,
and I was like,
man,
is he,
is he telling me the truth?
Is He really doing okay?
And it took time.
It took a long time.
The best thing for me is being able to
give back and um,
being able to come on this podcast and I
know after this podcast I'm going to
hit,
get hit up on social media a million
times and it'd be like,
Bro,
I'm dying.
I'm sick.
I'm drunk right now.
I'm crying and I'll,
and be like,
call me.
You know what I mean?
I'll call these people.
That's awesome.
I literally called them and they say,
I can't even believe I'm talking to you.
And I'm like,
I'm just a normal dude,
you know,
trick of the microphone.
Right?
Yeah.
And,
and so what's really beautiful is being
able to help these people.
And then,
you know,
forgetting about these people because
there's so many of them.
There's hundreds of emails and texts and
things at porn.
So you,
you,
uh,
you help them and then you move on to
the next guy.
But then three or four months later you
get this,
you know,
thank you letter.
You know that that says like,
Hey,
I completely turned my life around.
I'm
completely fine now.
You know what?
I'm sure some of them still go the other
way and you can't save everybody and
yeah,
you can't help everybody,
but you sure can try,
you know,
well,
you definitely make an impact and
podcasts like this always make an
impact.
There's people out there that are
listening right now and they might be in
their car,
they might be sitting at home just
trying to figure out what the fuck to do
with their life.
Sometimes all people need is that little
extra juice,
that little extra motivation that they
get from here.
Somebody like yourself that's gone
through it and came out on the other
side healthy and you're like,
fuck.
If he was crying,
looking in the mirror and feeling like
shit,
and he was addicted to drugs and,
and,
and he came from a healthy background
and he came from a background where he's
making a documentary about health.
When it got really bad,
um,
you know,
when,
when you start drinking in the morning,
it's really bad.
And,
uh,
alcohol became the worst part of it.
Worse than worse than even the pills.
And I just remember,
and they start selling alcohol in La at
6:00 AM.
And I remember I used to live right
across from Gold's gym in Venice.
And I get up and I walk across the
street at like five 45 because my car
was parked.
I had to park across the street right by
the gym.
I walk across the street over by the gym
and I'd see my friends going into the
gym for a workout and they'd be like,
Hey Chris,
what's going on?
You know,
I,
but be waving them.
I'd be going to the liquor store.
And that's when I knew it was like
really bad things needed to change.
So,
you know,
I,
I really do think that,
like you said,
um,
it takes somebody just like that little
thing.
So if there's people out there that are
listening to this,
just hit me up or hit up somebody and
tell them that you're hurting because
people will help you.
You need other people.
Well,
you're not going to do it on your own.
Everybody needs other people,
period.
That's this idea of the lone wolf is
total here.
I need the help other people in order
for me to be fulfilled for sure.
You know,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're all,
we're all together in this thing.
Yeah.
When having him at,
at my house,
you know,
really helped me a lot too.
Just just knowing that he was safe and
knowing he was doing the right thing.
I'm married,
I've got two kids.
I don't fuck around.
I train,
I fucking eat,
try to eat healthy.
I try to do the best I can each and
every day.
And having him with me made me more
accountable.
It made me more,
you know,
more full bore about everything.
So it worked out good for both of us.
Did you ever investigate Ibogaine?
Yeah,
I looked into it.
I talked to the top.
I knew,
I do know the top a researcher on
Ibogaine,
a doctor,
Deborah Mash.
Explain what that stuff is and what it
can do.
Ibogaine is a substance that you get it
from Africa,
found an Africa and basically you can
you drink it.
I think they make up some sort of potion
or whatever and you drink it.
And then literally what to turn a 20
year heroin addict around in about a
day,
about 36 hours they say.
And they,
they go through some ritual.
I'm not sure if the ritual does
anything.
Uh,
the doctor didn't even really know if
the ritual does data anything,
but it's part of the,
a placebo I guess.
But it seems to really work.
It's a schedule one drug here in
America.
You can't get it here.
Uh,
it's,
it's actually fairly safe compared to a
lot of other things.
So there's been some deaths it,
but it like maybe
15 all time or something like not,
not super high and it definitely needs
to be medically supervised,
but I don't think it should be illegal
in all.
I think it should be.
I think Ibogaine and Kratom or the
answers to the opioid epidemic,
well,
I began,
has an incredibly high rate of success
in terms of like people taking nine
began getting off pills.
I think Ibogaine is incredible.
I think Ed Clay,
uh,
opened up a clinic.
He went down,
he had a issue with pills as well and
I'm pretty sure,
I don't want to speak out of school,
but I'm pretty sure his came also from
an injury and then he got a,
had a pill problem and then was trying
to figure out what the fuck to do with
it and went down to Mexico,
went to an Ibogaine clinic and then
said,
wow,
this is fixed him up.
Totally.
And then,
uh,
opened up his own clinic.
That's awesome.
One thing I didn't understand is I
interviewed this doctor Deborah Mash,
and it's probably because she's in
Florida,
she's tied in with politicians,
which is always a problem.
And so she's 100% for Ibogaine,
but she's also against Kratom,
which makes no sense because she thinks
that,
uh,
you know,
Kratom is a,
because I will gain,
you have to go get it medically
supervising,
medically done.
And She just thinks like giving people
Kratom is a loosey Goosey kind of stuff,
man.
I'm 100% for clinics opening up and then
giving them under the doctors and give
the money to the state.
If you can get Ibogaine to the hands of
a lot of these people,
it's so ruthlessly introspective.
Not from my personal experience,
but arbors taken it.
I know several people who had taken it.
I know several people that have taken it
and it's completely turned their life
around where they had this intense 24
hour experience where you just examine
every single aspect of your life and
this really alien way.
And then after it's over,
you're like,
I am never fucking drinking again.
Or I'm never taken dance again.
And they really do change their life.
And it's also not just an introspective
experience,
but it also rewires the way your brain
handles the addiction.
I'm not qualified to speak how,
cause I don't really understand it.
I don't,
I don't know if anybody understands it.
Actually we could explain it.
Aubrey can explain the mechanism.
There's of some sort of a shift.
See if we could find that.
How does Ibogaine cure addiction?
So if you could find that,
but it's incredibly effective.
I mean,
I wash it highest rates of,
of a success.
Another super high rate of success that
we might be getting in California.
It's on the ballot in 2018 is legalizing
psilocybin.
If they gonna legalize silicide been,
that can fix a lot of fucking people
too.
And that's also something that you don't
die from.
Nobody.
Nobody's overdosing on psilocybin.
The ld 50 rate is something like 1500.
What does that,
what does that do?
What does it,
what does the magic mushrooms,
yeah.
And,
and that's for,
um,
mental health,
right?
Fermentable Johns Hopkins University did
some studies on it and one of the things
they found his soldiers with ptsd.
This is one thing that maps is
concentrating on now,
especially soldiers with ptsd and
anybody with Ptsd,
rape victims of a violent assault
victims.
You know,
some people have some real hard time
getting past past events and um,
psilocybin has incredible effects on
that,
but Mtma also does and right now maps is
involved in some pretty heavy clinical
trials with Mtma.
And um,
they're,
they think 2021 is around the time where
they're going to have mtma clinics and
then it'll be legal because we have so
many soldiers that are coming back from
war and they're all fucked up and they
have no solutions and put these people
on pills and antidepressants and all
these different things,
anti anxiety medication,
psilocybin and MDM may have shown to
have massive,
powerful,
beneficial effects.
That's something that I really want to
do.
I want to do the MDM a treatment I think
that,
um,
would a lot of people don't understand
is when you have an addiction,
there's like these,
there's deep seated things in your,
in your mind and your subconscious that
drive you to go to the pills or go to
the drinks or whatever.
And it doesn't just go away when you get
sober.
You sort of work a lot of it out.
But some of the subconscious stuff you
can't work out.
So I'm like,
man,
there's,
there's still things,
habits I don't like about myself.
There's still things I want to fix.
And I let me connect you to Aubrey
because he loves it.
Yeah.
He's really tight with those guys that
are in the middle of those studies right
now.
And he's actually gone through that
protocol and then operate a little bit.
Yeah.
Do you have his number?
Let me contact him and talk to him about
it because he's,
he's deep in this stuff.
You know,
Ombre who's introduced me to him when I
went down to your gym on a gym?
Yeah.
He's a,
what I would call real psychedelic
warrior.
And he's in there,
he's in there all the time and with some
crazy shit,
you know,
but there's the real benefits from it.
I mean,
real legit benefits.
And we've been,
we've been really robbed and it's,
it's terrible.
I mean,
we've been lied to.
We've been robbed and there's a lot of
people that use them recreationally.
And I'm not against that,
you know?
I mean,
I think you should be able do whatever
the fuck you want.
If you can drink whiskey recreationally,
which I do,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with doing mushrooms recreationally.
And there's some people that think it's
terrible and you should,
there are a sacrament.
We still use them in a ritual and a
shamonic setting.
I say,
you should do that too if you want.
But I've used it recreationally.
I've had a great old fucking time and
also came out of it with some insight
and some,
a different way of looking at myself and
looking at my life.
Do you know that,
um,
in this country you have to list
euphoria as a side effect to a
supplement or a drug wrestle area.
So euphoria is something that we all
should have.
Like we should all be happy,
right?
So they're listed as a side effect as if
it's a bad thing they experienced you
for ya.
Oh Shit,
I better not take that right.
Super fucking habit.
And don't you think the things that
induce euphoria we should be,
we should be handing those out like
crazy.
People are too angry.
He thinks these pills or maybe like
rehab pills kind of in a way like almost
like treatment pills because they help
you,
you know,
look from the inside out almost.
Well for sure with MDA,
which you get in pill form,
it's actually made from the bark of a
tree from,
didn't we go over this the other day
where the fucks are from Malaysia or
some shit,
something like that.
There's a tree and that there's a real
issue
now,
uh,
in this country where this bark is,
because you know,
this fucking wars going on to try to get
this tree and it's not a very common
tree either.
It's like,
I mean,
it's rare.
And we were,
we could be in a situation where they
chopped down all the fucking trees that
make ecstasy before we make it legal.
They did it with Kratom in Thailand.
So Thailand made kratom illegal because
it was cutting into the heroin,
the heroin trade,
this is back in 1947.
They made it illegal and cut down almost
all the Kratom trees.
And if you see the documentary that um,
uh,
the guy did on Vice Morris Hamilton
Morrison was,
yeah,
he did the Pharmacopoeia.
Yeah.
Shell on Kratom and he goes to Thailand
to find like the only remaining Kratom
tree.
And he like,
he finds it and wow drinks the real
kratom and all stuff like that.
It was really kind of fascinating that
they,
that they did that.
So now it all comes from like,
you know,
Malaysia,
Indonesia,
whenever it is crazy that they tried to
stop the one thing that's safe because
it was cutting into the fucking opium
market.
Yeah,
of course.
I like crate them too.
I use it before I work out a lot of
times.
You really?
Yeah.
And even just for creativity,
just like if I want to just sit down and
write or think of new products or
whatever,
it might be one,
two in that way.
How so?
I like it a lot.
Um,
I don't know exactly what it does.
I don't know what the mechanism is
behind it,
but it does give me a sense of euphoria.
It does make me happier.
One thing I've always noticed about
training is that when you feel good,
um,
you can lift so much better and it just
makes you,
makes you feel really great because you
know you're trying,
you're trying to lift with some force,
just like you hitting these bags and
stuff,
you're trying to put something into it.
And if you can't put the mustard on it
that you want to cause your shoulder
hurts,
I can make you grumpy.
But this stuff really matters to us.
So for me,
for for lifting wise,
it's like I feel like I can go all in.
I was actually just saying the other day
when I'm sitting down and I go to get
up,
especially after some of these like
squat workouts and stuff,
it's kind of slow.
He takes me,
takes me a minute,
but on Kratom boom,
I feel like I can get up and run out the
door.
It feels like almost,
I would see,
I would consider it similar to the
getting out of a hot tub with you feel
going into the hot tub.
You're like,
man,
my shit is just kind of,
I don't even know.
Everything's just stiff.
Right.
Can't get up and down the stairs so
good.
I got to do the sideways a trot down the
stairs every morning and I get in the
hot tub and I can zing up the stairs
naked picture that sometimes I have pain
in my hip when I don't run hills,
they don't sense men and I've talked to
doctors and they don't understand it.
I say,
look,
when I run hills every day or not every
day,
every week I run like two,
three times a week.
I got zero pain in that hip.
Could just be getting a lot of blood,
not in the hip flexor.
I think running hills and running,
uh,
running in sand I think is really,
really valuable.
Even pushing sleds and stuff because it
slows us down,
not that running is running can be great
sprints can be great,
but regular sprints for some of us who
are over 40
and you haven't sprinted in a long time,
probably not a great idea but to run up
a hill or to sprint up a hill,
it makes you go slower because the
intensity is higher
and it doesn't seem it's,
well I think that's it but it's also,
I'm putting all this extra muscle around
my hip and my ass like there's something
about that's great,
thank you very much.
But it's something about running up
hills that like,
dude,
I take a couple of weeks off,
like I was sick for a week and then the
week before that I was doing a lot of
other different shit and I didn't and it
starts to like get at me reverse hyper
doesn't help with that.
Would that would make him a hip.
It's going to front of the hip side to
side on that is you've got to get in on
that hip circle.
Hip Circle.
What's a show yet?
Oh,
band.
Yeah,
the hip Ben.
Yeah.
Those are great.
It'll help you that help build up that
side ass.
I like to call.
Is that what it is?
I'm telling you man,
there's nothing like running up hills
and the hills that I run,
it's all rocky terrain.
Some jumping from one rock to the next
and it's steep like that.
So I'm running up and um,
you know,
I have to take a couple of breaks to get
to the top.
It's a half a mile up,
a half a mile in.
I have two different courses that I run.
Um,
well they have several,
but the ones that I run the most,
the full length of it,
I could,
I could run as long as four miles or I
could do,
I could break it up into one or two.
Most of the time I do too.
How long are you runs?
Two hours,
uh,
to a miles takes me about 40 minutes
because the hills,
it's not two hours.
I mean,
it's not 40 minutes.
I could run it,
probably do it.
It's 15,
16.
If I was running flat,
you know,
I wouldn't be that hard.
But it's hills.
Um,
it's not really,
I mean I would call it running,
but it's more like hill sprints.
I'm just doing these roots was hill
sprints and I've read that a long time
ago that a lot of football players
prefer a hill sprints.
And then I saw that,
um,
Greg Jackson and Mike Winkeljohn when
they train their fighters now,
but Kirky they have them run this crazy
mountain and they run it and run
straight up the hill.
And that this was like a pig thing that
they did to,
to really build up.
And Darren and Walter Payton,
Roger Craig,
this goes on and on with Damian
Thompson.
Uh,
Walter Peyton used to run hills till he
throw up.
Yeah,
he threw up.
I think I'm running hills is great,
especially for bigger guys.
Guys that are two 50 to 60 to 70 have
joint problems.
It's going to be really hard to get out
there and run.
Yeah.
Cause you're not,
it's not a pounding,
you're not dropping the weight down.
Instead you're like,
you're almost doing like lunges like
over and over and over again.
Right.
And you could walk back down the hill,
you know,
take your time.
You can walk back down the hill.
There's evidence that shows if you do
five to eight sprints and you have long
periods,
you can have as much rest as you want
between,
you'll still get great results for fat
burning.
So yeah,
he doesn't take very long to do a
workout like that.
It changes your cardio too.
I mean,
it really does force him to do shit like
that with me sometimes.
But can you,
you can't run though,
right?
With your bad hand.
Not really run by pushing,
pushing a sled is really hard.
He has a thing called the tank,
which is a kind of an amazing,
a sled with wheels.
Oh,
you're pushing,
you put weights on it.
So we pushed the tank.
We do all sorts of stuff like that that,
um,
are different.
Like,
I can go on a rowing machine as fast as
possible.
I can go on a,
um,
the,
uh,
what do you call it?
The aerodyne bike as fast as possible.
The echo bike rogue.
It's a fucking tank.
It's like an Airdyne on steroids.
It's got these big ass fucking handles
and that it looks nice.
It's so good.
Plus to something as simple as that and,
and those bikes that you can get them as
cheap as like 500 bucks.
Yeah.
I think it'll change your life.
Just like mark said,
five to eight sprints on it a day.
Yeah.
It's completely,
when he comes up and trained with me,
when he comes up and trains with me,
a lot of times he'll say,
I can't do that.
I try to,
you know how everybody in these kind of
big circuits that we do and we,
we train our asses off and probably
sometimes overdo it,
but when he joins us,
a lot of times they'll say,
I can't do this or I can't do that.
I'm like,
well,
you don't really know unless you try it.
And I,
I'm sympathetic towards fake hips.
I don't have them,
so I don't know exactly what it's like,
but I'm like,
just try it or try a different variation
of it.
And He,
he kind of won't.
And then he'll kind of drift off and the
next minute I'll see him,
I'll see him either trying it or trying
or doing some other version of it.
And I'm like,
all right,
good.
It's working cause he's at least doing
something.
Right.
Do you fuck with the versaclimber?
Yeah,
we do that a little bit sometimes.
Stoughton's
hate your life.
We do a circuit with that.
And I have a bike that's on steroids to,
oh sh so from Australia,
I forget what the theme at the end
please.
Our two.
Oh yeah.
We have the uh,
uh,
ski Erg thing.
Oh those things are ruthless.
We use that and the rower and we do a
circuit of all,
like all three or four of those
exercises.
Yeah.
That's fucking awesome.
I got,
when I started editing it,
adding in a lot more things like that
and cardio and stuff like that because,
uh,
I'm 45.
He's,
how old are you?
41 40.
[inaudible] so as we get older,
you start looking into things where,
uh,
you want to be healthy,
you know,
I want to do it for your health.
So I'm thinking about those things.
A,
we definitely,
I don't care about power lifting
anymore.
I don't care about my numbers.
I want to lift heavy weights
consistently,
but I don't care what the single rep
maxes anymore.
It doesn't matter.
You know?
Um,
when you talk about your diet and its
impact on inflammation,
do you ever think that if you got on
this diet when you were younger,
you wouldn't have had to get hip
replacements?
Yeah,
I do.
I really do.
I think if I did when I was younger,
um,
well,
I don't know.
You know,
it's about a,
it really is about a decline and I'm in
tissue,
you know,
he'd decline in cartilage tissue,
like where it was there when I was young
and then it started disappearing.
And then by the time I was 28 years old,
it was completely gone.
And this is because of inflammation and
because of arthritis,
there's really no reason for it.
You know,
my doctor said that lifting didn't cause
it.
It might have sped it up.
The fact that I needed to get the double
hip replacement surgery,
but he said like this isn't something
that,
you know,
lifting a weight causes like a natural
process in your body where you're,
your body's breaking down,
you know,
whatever.
So I don't,
I don't know a good test will five years
from now how I feel,
you know,
because I have other joints in my body,
a lot of them.
I was just going to ask you like,
how are your shoulders?
How are your,
well,
I screwed up my shoulder and I tore my
rotator cuff and I tore my tricep a
while back and they never really heal,
healed properly,
so that,
that's an issue.
Um,
but the rest of my other joints that
aren't,
are injured are all fine and feel good
now.
You know?
So what about your needs?
Well,
my knees were when I had got my hip
surgery 10 years ago.
Uh,
the doctor said to me,
your knees are next and they need to be
done probably like in a year.
God,
so he told me that when 10 years ago
he's got a Ferrari and I'm making
payments on that Condo in the Alps and
uh,
I don't know.
I haven't had,
and then,
um,
let's see,
I'm trying to think of when this was.
I think like around when I finished
prescription thugs,
so maybe like two years ago,
uh,
I was,
I went to a doctor and I was just in so
much pain and I said,
look,
I can't get back on opioids.
That was,
that was my problem,
but I need something.
What was the pain in everywhere.
Every joint in my lower body from my,
like my ankles,
my knees,
my hips,
and the guy basically just said,
you need to go get a full body MRI.
So I get a full body Mri and he tells me
that there's really nothing wrong with
me.
And I'm like,
I don't know what you're looking at,
but I can't walk in the morning.
And he's like,
ah,
well you don't,
you don't really have,
you know,
like you're,
you don't really have cartilage in your
knees that's going away,
but like,
you know,
you do have it in your ankles and you do
have,
and didn't really offer me any
solutions.
And then that was,
it was at that point where I realized
like,
if I'm going to do anything,
a doctor's not going to be the one to
help me,
you know?
So I think a lot of times people are
always so concerned,
like,
did you ask a doctor?
And I'm always like,
with doctors never really helped me.
You know,
it's my cell phone.
He's helping me.
It's me researching things that caused
me pain,
that,
that really helped me,
you know?
So,
um,
that's,
that's what I had to do was go out and
look for it myself.
Wow.
So when you,
do you ever go back to that doctor and
go,
hey motherfucker,
it's 10 years later,
I'm still walking and now I don't have
any pain.
I should go back to him and say,
hey,
you know,
like they,
they screwed up my hip and they left.
They left a bad hip and me for two
years.
And then I went to the doctor and I went
to my doctor and I said,
doc,
this is debilitating.
And so he takes a,
a tissue box and he throws it on the
ground and he says,
pick that up.
And I pick it up.
And he said,
you're using the wrong terminology.
It's not debilitating.
I'll see.
You wouldn't be able to pick that up.
And I thought it was the rudest thing
I've ever heard a doctor do or say like
ruthless,
like really?
So I'm using the wrong word,
but big.
I can't,
I can't pick something up off the floor.
It hurts.
And I was trying to tell him like,
you don't understand this hurts.
And he's like,
Nah,
you're not hurt,
you're fine.
He actually told me to go back to the
gym and start lifting.
Oh my God.
And then two years later he calls me
back and he says,
I know what's wrong with your hip.
We screwed it up.
Oh Jesus.
Yeah.
So it's everything about column on that
doctors on late night TV.
Yeah.
You know,
think,
I don't think that's the,
you know,
you don't get as a way to get paid,
I'm
sure.
Yeah.
But they fucked you up man.
Just sue the shit out of that asshole
tissue box.
Throwing douchebag.
Fuck them.
Part of what happened to you too was
like you had pain,
right?
That was a,
that was preventing you from moving
more,
right?
Like,
and then you just kind of stopped.
Like you did some cardio stuff for
exercise,
but you weren't able to squat,
bench deadlift.
You weren't able to get some full range
of motion and therefore,
you know,
use it or lose it.
Right.
You lost range of motion.
When did the pain go away?
Uh,
well,
I'm still on a lot of pain when I wake
up every morning.
So yeah,
it goes away when I,
the thing is that the diet has helped
clear up like a lot of inflammation.
It's also helped clear up a lot of body
fat,
which helps you get in a better and more
advantageous positions when you're
lifting.
You know that you can't,
I couldn't even bend down to dead lift
properly.
Egg got would get in a way and all that
stuff like that.
So,
um,
get rid of those things and that helps a
lot.
Losing weight in general always is going
to improve health markers and you're
always going to feel lighter and better,
you know,
for the most part.
And then,
um,
it was that this like losing weight.
And then when I,
um,
started taking Kratom with a ketogenetic
diet and really reduce my inflammation
is when I started feeling better.
So was sort of a combination of those
two things.
And I'm continuing to move.
It's a daily struggle.
It doesn't go away.
You know,
this,
this is because your osteoporosis
osteoarthritis.
So when you woke up this morning,
what hard to get out of bed?
Yeah.
You know what?
Actually,
um,
this morning I felt good.
So you have good days and bad days,
you know?
Did you ever fuck with hot yoga?
I haven't,
but I keep hearing you talk about it and
I keep thinking like,
man,
that's just something I have to go do.
I was wondering like how that would
affect your hips.
Like how you're like,
do you have full range of motion?
I think I would probably feel great but
right now I can't move enough to get in
those positions so I have to take like a
pre yoga class to get into,
you know,
you just take a yoga class and you do
your best.
Like they always say that because
there's a lot of people in my class that
have some serious issues that can't move
well or there's this one lady who goes
and she's fucking courageous man cause
this lady's so overweight and she goes
this yoga class and she does her best
and you know,
I see her and I,
I want to say something to her but I
don't want to say something to her.
Like I don't want to be the guy and go,
hey you know for a giant lady you're
fucking putting it up there.
Like I don't want to like,
you know,
you're right.
I say hi and I smile at her,
but she's courageous.
She's every bit of 400 5,500 pounds.
Wow.
Just guessing.
She is enormous,
but she does it.
She tries,
she's,
you know,
she's got her arms up.
She's been in for it.
She's doing her best.
And if you just keep showing up,
it'll get better.
Like you're not going to be able to get
into those positions initially,
but if you keep showing up,
I think the hot yoga might help him
because,
uh,
when he's warmed up,
you move around really well.
That's what I'm sending work workout.
You're like,
oh fuck it.
Now I'm going to dead lift once he's
warmed up.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't warm up enough.
Right.
I agree,
man.
You're 100% in a yoga class where it's
already warm.
That helps a lot.
But you know,
people need to understand that the more
intense the exercise is that you're
going to do,
the longer your warm up needs to be.
Yeah.
So if you're going for a two hour walk,
how much warm up do you need?
Probably none.
There's no one,
there's not a lot of intensity behind
that.
But if you're trying to run a 40 meter
sprints,
then you better warm up for a half an
hour and probably minimum.
So you don't tear a hamstring.
Same thing with trying to bench heavy or
squat heavy,
not just the exercise itself either.
That's a mistake I think.
I think you have to warm up on with
other,
with other means.
And the easiest way to warm up is
through your upper body.
So you go in the gym and you can do
curls and shoulder stuff if your
shoulders healthy.
Uh,
that's the fastest way.
Skier is a great way.
That's fastest,
easiest way to warm up your body is
through the upper body a lot of times
are our needs.
What do you mean?
Well cause like your knees and your
lower back.
I mean just in general,
this is an everybody but in general a
lot of people,
the knees,
the lower back and some of those things
are going to take time to warm up and
you can warm up faster just by,
just by getting the upper body to move.
Uh,
when you utilize your upper body,
you get your heart rate up a little bit
faster and it's just,
it's more comfortable.
It's just easier.
It's easier for me to say,
Hey,
you know,
hold this band,
pull it apart,
do these curls.
He just move your arms,
throw some punches,
like who can't throw punches.
Right.
Anyone can throw some punches.
I know you guys can throw any good ones.
Yeah,
no,
you can't do any good ones.
Yeah,
but you just,
you move around.
That's how you warm yourself up.
You've got to make sure you warm
yourself up.
I get to use the elliptical machine.
I do 10 minutes on an elliptical
machine.
Absolutely nothing going on as the
intensity,
so low and there's no impact,
no nothing.
You can do it at your own pace and not
really caring.
And mark and I do all the time is walk.
We walk every single day.
And um,
we started a thing like a 10 minute,
he does has a Hashtag 10 minute walk and
uh,
after,
after you eat every time,
right?
Yeah.
You try to do as many 10 minute walks in
the days it can.
Anybody about that Hashtag because now
they're going to put a picture of a
bunch of pictures of Dicks Hashtag
[inaudible] hey,
that's okay.
Yeah,
I get it.
I get a lot of good balance plants.
I don't know.
Now it's even worse cause I said it here
like some inside joke about eggplants,
tons of eggplants,
eggplants a Dick,
right?
What kinds of things,
Yeah,
for sure.
100% yeah.
Oh I didn't know.
Yeah.
Oh now you're getting lockers.
That's,
it's so funny.
I'm so,
I'm so old.
I don't know anything the kids are doing
these days.
I just found out about a little bee.
I don't know shit.
Anyway,
people should be going on a 10 minute
walk.
It's low hanging fruit.
It's easy to do.
Just try one a day.
It's not hard.
One thing I like to do is body weight
squats.
To do those Hindu squats,
I'll do a set of a hundred and it just
gets everything warmed up.
Everything League,
get your legs burning pretty bad in a
weird spot,
right?
Like your quads near your knee.
Upper knee?
Yeah.
Like right here.
This,
this part like right where your need
connects.
Where your quad,
that handy spot.
What about,
what about a wall?
Sit.
How come a wall sit so hard?
It's fucking hard.
I did that the other day.
It was brutal.
It was the hardest fucking exercise.
There isn't,
well,
in karate they would have you stand at a
horse stance for long periods of time.
Just like this.
Just standing at horse dance like how
hard could this be?
A minute and you're like,
oh shit.
How am I supposed to do this?
You're not even leaning up against the
wall.
Yeah.
No.
Lean up against the wall.
Just a deep squat
to stand and how long we you standing
for it?
I never did it.
It was not,
my instructor was never ended up.
Well I didn't.
I took karate for a very short period of
time.
That's a karate thing.
That was in taekwondo.
He never did that.
Karate kids coming back.
Oh my God.
You know about Ai.
Is it a will smith junior again?
No,
no,
it's Cobra Kai.
It's a show about the Cobra Kai.
It's like Netflix that's about the bags
and Netflix on youtube,
but Ralph Machos in it and he comes in
and he has a competing Dojo I believe.
How old is Ralph Macho now?
50 30 to least he looks great.
Like what does that guy on the trade
show is on some youth shit.
Oh,
you just go look at Cobra Kai.
Let me see the strike hard.
Oh,
pushups.
terrible punches.
It was teaching these people.
No mercy.
Is there any particular way you want me
to
shut them out with that?
Shut that off right now.
That was great.
There you go.
That is the fucking trailer we need an
MMA movie.
Get to,
there was one warrior,
Brian town was in that.
The only problem with that movie is they
had people fight over a couple of days,
which is just like shut the fuck up.
They did a bunch of stupid shit.
They didn't have to do in that movie.
They just,
you don't have people.
You can have people fight more than a
one time and the night.
But if you really think someone can get
in a bra and then you've never seen
anybody fight and then see what they
look like the next day.
Cause I remember when Ken shamrock
fought Tito Ortiz and then I ran into
him the next day.
I was like,
Holy Shit can,
his whole face was swollen up.
He had sunglasses on it.
If that guy is not fighting any today,
you know,
I mean he would,
he's a fucking animal but that's not
healthy.
Like your body's dealing with all that.
I don't even like when they fight more
than one time in the night and they got
away with that back in the day.
And I know glory still does that for
some of the kickboxing tournaments,
but it's his fucking dangerous.
It's just not smart.
Guys get concussed and then they fight
again an hour later,
two hours later.
That's crazy.
Smashing machine was a fucking awesome
movie.
That's my favorite documentary ever.
That is my top and that's an accidental
fine.
That's when I was documentaries.
Amazing Doc.
That is a lot like that movie icarus
where they started to do one thing and
then a long yeah,
they found something way fucking crazy.
Yeah.
And that's uh,
a documentary around Mark Kerr who was
one of the scariest mma fighters of all
time and he was Jews to the,
but there was such an ironic thing with
him where he was an animal,
but he was so afraid to actually fight,
which was really cool.
Where that,
that was such an interesting angle you'd
say before he goes out to the cage every
time he's like,
I can barely take a sip of water because
I'm so nervous because that kills
people.
I was around when Mark Kerr first
started competing.
He's one of the first guys that ever
saw,
first of all,
he was a gi and they used to call him
the specimen for a while.
Then they called them the smashing
machine.
But uh,
he's the first guy that ever saw that
submitted someone with a look of that
shit the fuck out of here.
That's crazy.
It's like,
I can improve that.
Um,
but look at that.
Just keep that up there for a second.
And those traps when he was a,
that's pretty at the UFC,
he submitted someone with a chin to the
eye socket.
He held the back of the dude's head and
got his chin and the guy's eye socket
and you're fucking drove his chin into
his eye socket Dan [inaudible].
Yeah,
first time I ever saw somebody submit
someone that way.
But seriously everybody asks me what my
favorite documentary is cause that's
what I do.
And without even hesitation,
I always say smashing machine.
It's a great documentary on so many
levels.
It really reminded me of our older
brother.
He reminded me a lot of mad dog.
Wow.
Mark her.
Well you know he had a substance abuse
problem and he was also like a guy at
the time.
It was the early days of MMA.
I mean he was fighting back when it was
just crazy raw bare knuckles and you
know,
fighting in these weird rings and Shammy
and he was the early,
early days of MMA.
You ever read the book blood in the
cage?
I read some of it's really good.
I never feel like you had pat on a last
week and actually wanted to do,
I still want to do a film with Pat,
a scripted film.
We had been talking about it,
we talked about it a long time ago and
now I'm starting started,
started adding a little bit of clout.
Now I'm starting to talk about it again,
but his life was insane.
He had two brothers that died and one
brother that ended up going to jail for
like 15 years and he was the runt of the
family and he ended up becoming the
first ever UFC lightweight champion,
which is just overcoming adversity like
crazy.
It's an amazing story.
You know,
pats neck was so fucked up that his
discs fuse together on their own.
Wow.
That's incredible.
It's so much degeneration of his disks
that the two bones,
they sat on top of each other for so
long that they fused the port where
people accused him of having an
operation.
Like he had an issue where a doctor said
that he had an operations.
I never had a fucking operation like
your neck,
your fucking boone's the two bones.
They have no disc in the middle,
another fuse together.
I've never even heard of that before.
You ever heard of that before?
No.
Fucking tough.
You have to be to deal with kind of pain
where your neck is fusing itself.
Your neck is like,
this asshole is not going to go to a
doctor,
so we're going to be the doctor.
When you see what he went through a,
he's probably one of the toughest people
and the world,
you know,
just that.
She's been through a lot of very smart
dude too.
He's talked to him.
He's there,
he's all there.
I mean long career in mma,
you know,
he fought Dan Severn finished a book.
If you get a chance,
it's amazing.
Okay.
Listen to the audio book when you run or
something.
That's great.
Really good book.
Um,
yeah,
he's,
it's those old days.
There's nothing like them.
Never happened again.
What's great about that book.
Also,
it tells the whole story of the,
how the UFC started,
how it got us started and all the
players involved.
And it tells that whole story,
which is really putting a Jon Wertheim
sports illustrated,
really,
really good writer.
That guy has written a lot of good
stuff.
He wrote a great book on pool too.
Yeah,
he wrote a book on delicious.
He brought the pool book.
He wrote a book on statistics and how
they sort of a point shave and all that
stuff on that in basketball.
No,
he's a,
he's a very good writer.
Okay,
cool.
Uh,
when is,
uh,
do you think this documentary is gonna
come out the new [inaudible]?
Well,
the creative ones gonna come out soon,
right?
Eight 29 and then what's it going to be
on?
How's it,
where can people get it?
Well,
hopefully it will be on like Netflix,
Amazon,
whatever.
I'm not sure exactly where it will be
yet.
We've partnered with the orchard and
there's the distribution companies.
So right now they're in the process of
figuring out where it will be.
Um,
but I'll let everybody know.
It'll be on it.
Probably start out to tell you the truth
on itunes,
the normal route.
And then,
um,
you know,
you let it play on itunes for a while
and hey,
there's a,
there's a whole system to it because it
makes money in different ways,
different places.
Right.
Unfortunately for documentary film
makers,
Netflix is sort of your,
that's your graveyard at the end because
you know,
like you want it to be on Netflix
because everybody has access to it.
And as a film maker,
they really shaft you can because
they'll buy the like,
so they buy the film from the
distribution company and then like all
that money just goes back to the
investor and then,
and it's like,
I don't get,
I don't see any money out of it.
So the only way to make documentaries
and make them profitable and make them
really,
really cheap.
And a lot of times we don't do that,
so we ended up,
you end up losing some money on it a lot
of times,
you know,
the way it's just the way it works.
This nutrition movie.
Yeah.
Find that millionaire money.
That's 100%.
Yeah.
But you know,
the advantage of doing a food
documentaries,
they do really well.
So it would a food documentary,
you have a chance to really make a
profit.
Where as the other stuff it's,
it's really difficult.
Did you gotten the term meathead
billionaire yet?
A trademark.
Yeah.
Did you I got all kinds of stupid shit.
Trademarks.
That's a good thing.
That was my nickname for him
had millionaire.
Well I know that,
uh,
it grows,
did really well and it did really well.
Bryan Fogel,
you know,
but that is a groundbreaking boss life
changing documentary.
Also things break out like that.
Like that might be,
first of all,
it was involved,
you know,
when we did bigger,
stronger,
faster,
there wasn't an international scandal
going on right.
That we were sorta happened to be
following.
And so,
yeah.
So,
so,
um,
in a way,
you know,
he got,
he got lucky with that,
but he also made a great film.
He took it and made it into something
really good.
So I think that was cool.
But,
uh,
you know,
it,
it was what a crazy movie that was.
You know,
we didn't,
we didn't have something like that in
the movie.
We didn't have somebody like admitting
to steroids that was like huge.
So,
uh,
when it came out at Sundance,
it was sort of a shocker to a lot of
people like,
this is at Sundance.
This is crazy.
I can't believe this,
you know,
at Sundance.
And um,
and it did really well.
It got really good reviews.
It did really well,
but it didn't have that like one thing
that broke it out and made it super size
me,
you know,
there was,
there was something missing,
some element where every,
you know,
it wasn't a thing that everybody had to
see.
Although it was a really great film,
I think,
you know,
it just didn't have that one thing that
was really great as well.
But yeah,
you didn't,
he got super lucky while he was doing,
you know,
you could see what I'm saying now.
It wasn't that one thing.
We had to see it because of this thing,
you know?
It's like,
yeah,
because there's always the thing about
cheating in the Olympic Games,
it's always been suspected,
but to get it so confirmed where you
have the guy that did it and he's
running from the Russian mob or the
whatever you want to call them,
and they're trying to fucking kill him.
It was,
no,
he's in hiding.
He's still in hiding to this day in
America in protective custody.
And they're looking for him.
Yeah,
they're looking for him.
I think it's crazy.
First of all that he did,
did the film and I think secondly,
it's crazy that,
um,
he wasn't even a little bit more
protected in the least by the film
maker.
I thought the film maker kind of throw
him under the bus a little bit,
but that's just how so are you wanted to
be in the film?
Yeah,
I know.
It was,
it was weird though.
It started to feel weird.
I felt like,
um,
I dunno.
I mean like the daddy of protected by
changing is named that the Russians knew
who he was.
Yeah.
I,
I don't know.
I just,
I just felt like it was,
um,
I dunno.
I felt like it was a little reckless as
a filmmaker,
you know,
I just felt like it was a,
what would you do differently?
It's tell you the truth.
I really,
I really don't know what I would do
differently.
I just felt like,
man,
this like as I'm watching it going like,
this guy's going to get in a lot of
trouble.
He's going to get killed because of
this.
He threw me in so I don't,
I don't know.
Maybe I did.
Maybe I do.
Maybe I'm just talking out my ass.
But you weren't like rigging the
Olympics.
But what changed after that was that the
Russians essentially are barred from the
Olympics and now they compete in the
Olympic final.
What's interesting is we,
they had don Catlin in there and Don
Catlin guy for America that does the
same thing.
Does he?
And he was gonna,
he was gonna be the first guy I
remember.
Then he backed out and he said,
I'll give you the Russian guy.
Cause he knew the Russian guy,
he taught does it for America.
He,
he's the guy that's our doping control.
Like he are doping control guy.
He's our,
our um,
what,
you saw a guy or he,
he's a guy that did all the drug test
for the Olympics from like the eighties
on.
But he's not the guy that dopes up the
American Nazi doesn't really clearly he
doesn't dope them up.
He's the guy that tests them.
We should tell people what ecourses too
if they don't know what we're talking
about.
So this would be a standalone podcast.
It's documentary that Bryan Fogel made
where he decided to rice rice a ride his
bike in a race.
So clean,
completely clean,
and then do it on steroids to see what
his times would be,
how much,
how much benefit it would have.
And in the process of him filming this
documentary,
the guy who hooked him up,
this guy,
gregory from Russia,
who was the head unbeknownst to him of
the Russian state sponsored doping
program,
he was like,
he thought he was getting a guy who was
like the rush and you saw that,
that it was going to tell him what
the cheaters use.
But it turned out along the way,
everything got exposed and he was like,
look,
I did this for 40 years.
I dope everybody,
everybody on drugs.
And like he said,
every fucking single athlete that was in
the Olympics was on some shit.
And then he explained how they did it
and everybody's like,
what the fuck?
And then they were going to pull the
Russians.
And then the other thing that he exposed
is the,
the collusion between water and the IOC
and that they all work for each other
and they switched fucking rolls and they
go back and forth to each other and that
they're not going to punish the Russians
and that.
But what they're doing now is they kind
of have to,
because all of that movie,
I mean that movie literally changed the
Olympics.
I guess what I'm saying is when I did
bigger,
stronger,
faster,
and we're going around and talking to
the experts,
you know,
a lot of the experts,
they would mention gone catlin.
I'd be like,
what's up with Don Catlin?
And they'd say,
Oh man,
if you get him to talk,
I mean the sports world will just
crumble.
And everybody kept saying it like,
I heard it from like four to people.
How,
sorry,
experts.
They just said like nobody would believe
in sports if that guy expose what he
knew.
And so then I interviewed Don Catlin,
but he just laughed when I asked him.
And he's like,
God,
they don't know what they're talking
about,
you know,
kind of thing.
And you're to know,
I'll see you guys later.
And I said,
well,
look,
Charles East St Louis is an expert.
He said,
the whole sports will crumble if they,
if they knew what you knew,
what do you know?
And he said,
I don't know anything.
And so you're not,
you're never going to get an answer like
that.
Something has to get exposed through a
different way.
So I shouldn't,
I can't say without a ship,
without a shadow,
beyond a shadow of a doubt that that's
the truth.
But I suspicious of that guy,
I should say,
and suspicious of our system.
I don't think they're the only ones
doing it.
There's no way that the only ones doing
that China had a record number of gold
medals when they hosted it.
We're doing it just as bad as they are.
I wonder,
I mean,
we're doing it better.
Obviously we're not,
we're not getting caught.
But I mean,
so when you say we as a country state
sponsored a marrow,
no,
no program.
I don't think state sponsored.
But I'd think like maybe some people
doing something somewhere.
There's some sort of network,
some shenanigans.
There's one balco there's 10.
There's gotta be more than one bowel.
Yeah,
I think so.
There's gotta be more than one guy
that's like telling people what to take.
A lot of that shit out there.
But listen,
man,
keep me posted on your movie.
Let us know when,
when this nutrition,
do you have a name for it yet?
Uh,
we've been,
we've been talking about on carbs.
So you're talking about the war cars
with,
we've been debating whether or not
that's the right,
it's a very catchy things,
especially now because people are so
aware.
There's so many people that are
switching to low carb,
high fat diets and having some pretty
spectacular results.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of,
there's a lot of evidence behind it.
You know,
and if you,
you were saying before,
I'd like to see somebody take all these
diets and compare them.
And they did that in the 70s or the 80s,
I forget when it was.
It was Dr. Gardner from Stanford and he
was a vegetarian,
so he took a Vegan diet,
vegetarian diet.
The Atkins Diet was the Diet at the
time.
It wasn't like a Keto Diet,
um,
the dash diet and the ornish diet.
And He'd put them all together and they
did a lot,
like a pretty big elaborate,
I don't know how big it was.
So,
I don't want to say,
but they're pretty elaborate study.
And at the end of the day,
the Atkins Diet,
basically one most weight loss,
best health marker improvement,
Atkins Diet,
and the guy who was a vegetarian and he
said at the end of the study,
this was a really tough pill to swallow.
You know,
and I think that's a really interesting
thing.
They did this study.
Did you know that Atkins had a bunch of
heart attacks?
Coronary heart disease is 258 pounds
when he died.
Yeah.
And um,
someone was saying,
well heard that stuff wasn't true
though.
No,
no,
no.
He was,
no,
he,
that's how big he was when he died.
And it definitely had heart disease.
So it definitely did.
But the question is,
did he have heart disease before he did
this diet was even on his own diet.
I mean,
was his diet based on science and fact
and,
and efficacy.
But did he follow it or did he just eat
ice cream?
Fuck off all day?
We don't know.
But he died by hitting his head.
Right.
It fell on his head.
Fell and hit his head.
But see,
this all came from a tweak that I read
from John Joseph from the Cro mags,
who's a pretty rampant,
a rabid vegan and a bad ass,
you know,
triathlete and very,
very athletic guy.
Right.
Um,
he's,
he is the one that said that and I was,
oh wow.
Is that true?
And he said that the guy died of a heart
attack and that his wife was covering it
up.
So I went to look into it and it's very
difficult to say because,
um,
even snopes had as inconclusive.
Yeah.
It's like,
Ooh.
Like he might have had a heart attack
and fell and hit his head.
It's,
I mean the guy had heart disease,
but the question is,
look,
some people have heart disease and it's
congenital.
They're born with issues and there is,
there,
there are people that are more,
I mean,
they're just more likely to have heart
attacks,
just like to some people that are more
likely to have strokes and more likely
to have arthritis.
There's just issues that people have.
So we don't know whether or not he was
born with that.
If he had that,
but also if he's at 258 pounds,
he clearly isn't following it's fucking
diet unless he's a giant.
Yeah.
How old was he?
He was an old guy and he's in his
seventies,
I believe.
Maybe late sixties.
Find it.
Pull,
pull,
pull up the,
um,
the Wiki on him on,
uh,
Dr. Atkins.
What was his name
from Robert?
Robert Atkins.
But you know how he died?
Yeah,
that's the thing.
It was like,
um,
you were talking about him,
the guy.
Yeah.
But the Diet that he created is
different than the actual guy.
Right.
And we don't know if he was doing his
diet.
So we call that the people who were
doing this diet that were in the study.
Right.
They ended up coming out on top as well.
I'm saying the guy who created crossfit,
he's not in shape.
Right?
I mean,
you ever see him?
Yeah.
He,
he's got some issues,
I believe some injuries and stuff that
don't allow him to do all this stuff to
crossfit does.
Right.
But yeah,
he's
[inaudible] 72 when he died,
days prior to his death,
he fell and hit his head and see New
York pavement,
a New York's blah,
blah,
blah.
Admitted April 8th he underwent surgery
to remove a blood clot in his brain but
went into a coma.
So we don't know.
I mean it says that's how he fell and he
hit his head.
We don't know why he fell and it may
very well have been that,
but here it says metal exam has offered
her office a year after his death showed
that Atkins had a history of heart
attack.
Can jet congestive heart failure?
What does congestive heart failure and
hypertension ingestive means.
Okay,
that's not good.
His widow refuse to allow an autopsy.
Oh that's interesting.
That is interesting because does Wa
widow refuse to allow an autopsy because
this guy wasn't healthy and maybe wasn't
even following his own advice,
but he was,
what was his weight when he died?
Maybe cause it's going to say that
Jamie,
his wife might've felt that he's going
to get ripped apart in his death and she
didn't want that.
Maybe 72 years old.
You can find out what his weight was
when he died.
Cause I'm pretty sure he was 258 pounds
and you're 258 pounds.
It's 72 years old.
That shit ain't good.
You know,
does it say is,
wait,
I'm very,
very sure that he was very heavy.
Robert Atkins,
258 pounds when he died.
I'm pretty sure that's how.
So here's the thing,
was that from the Diet,
I mean it does.
How's that possible?
I mean if the guy's making people lose
weight on this diet and he himself is
fat and he himself has serious heart
failure,
258 pounds,
that is dell release report by New York
City officials outrage the act and
Atkins people.
So he had a history of heart attacks and
congestive heart failure and 258 pounds.
Well I don't think he exercised.
I think he probably didn't,
but that doesn't mean anything.
I mean the over eight obviously too,
but it's like,
was the guy following his own advice?
We don't know.
There's a lot of people that look,
I think at this cream is tempting per
spaghetti's tempting,
you know,
who doesn't like a good meatball sub
every now and again?
Who knows?
At the end of the day,
we're all on this a race who can see
who's going to live the longest.
Right.
And I there,
I think that's,
there's still no like real conclusive
proof is there that one diet people can
live longer,
but forget about the other longest
because that's really out of your
control.
What about the quality of life while
you're alive?
That's what I think of.
If you're 258 lbs,
your quality of life sucks unless you're
a giant.
Unless he's as big as Frances and Ghana,
you know?
I mean really literally.
That's like in Ghana,
his weight class.
How the fuck?
Yeah,
that was,
is that how that big,
let's Atkins is fucking giant gorilla.
I mean,
how was he?
How was he have 258 pounds?
That's not good.
I agree with you.
Quality of life.
Like,
if I'm here,
you know,
if I'm going to get an extra two years,
but I'm going to be like weak and feeble
and not able to do anything,
like what are those two years' worth?
It I feel that the best diet is the one
you can follow.
And utilizing a ketogenic style diet and
utilizing intermittent fasting,
I think it helps kill hunger.
I think it helps kill cravings.
And so I think it's a diet that in my
opinion one of the easier diets to to it
might be hard
for some people that really like carbs
and they might have to find something
different.
Uh,
but for me it's always worked for him
it's always worked well.
He is essential.
Atkins Diet did put people into ketosis.
Yeah.
Fed.
It wasn't really the um,
the goal of it.
It wasn't a goal to get weird shit to
eat a lot of like bars and things like
that.
You intake sugar,
alcohol and a lot of things in there
that probably are just not great for you
to imagine.
Those atkins bars are really good if you
like to Fart.
Yeah.
I mean that stuff is fun.
Clear a room.
They make some crazy stuff and like,
like chocolate,
caramel,
anything that's going to be like that
can't be good for you in any way really.
You know,
flavors.
Yeah.
It's all fake.
And that's hot farts.
Yeah.
Whether you're doing a ketogenic diet,
a Vegan diet or any diet,
you should stick to real whole foods.
And one of the things Rob Wolf taught me
was,
you know,
by things that don't have nutrition
labels on them.
And just that simple thing.
When you think about it,
you're like,
yeah,
if I buy vegetables all neat and it
doesn't have that.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Let's wrap this up.
Uh,
big,
strong fast on twitter.
Mark Smelly Bell on twitter.
Uh,
tell people about your gym.
I got super training gym in West
Sacramento.
The gym is free.
We're having a seminar April 22nd.
If you want to come out the gym,
how the fuck do you survive with the
gym?
That's free.
And he had millionaire,
cause I got a lot of products.
I invented a product called the
slingshot.
People just work out at your gym.
I let people just work out at my gym.
Good luck.
It's going to be a fucking cavalcade.
A psychopath.
That's to a gym.
That's okay.
We,
we,
uh,
we welcome and I love awesome.
I love helping other people.
I've teaching other people.
I love coach and other people.
Fucking beautiful human being,
Eh.
All right,
well,
uh,
and tell people where it is.
Again,
check out my website.
Mark Bell's slingshot.com and super
training gym is in West Sacramento,
California.
All right,
that's it folks.
See you guys back tomorrow with bus
route and Whoa.
[inaudible].